YOUR CAMERA AND YOUR MICROPHONE.
HEY OKAY I CAN HEAR.
SEEING.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YEP I CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY AND ARE YOU GONNA USE
YOUR VIDEO. OR NO VIDEO. THERE
YOU GO I CAN SEE YOU NOW. THANK
YOU. WELL WELCOME EVERYBODY
HAPPY ST PATRICK'S DAY THIS
SEVENTEENTH DAY OF MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- IS TO WALK INTO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING-
REGARDING THE- FORMER EQUITY
ACT NOW I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES WHO JOINED US HERE
TODAY AS WELL AS THOSE
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY I KNOW I
GOT- NOTICED THAT TWO OF OUR
MEMBERS WOULD BE DOING THIS
REMOTELY THAT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VIA- I AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANK YOU ARE CARILLO
UNFORTUNATELY HAD A SCHEDULING
CONFLICT SO SHE'S GOING TO BE
WITH US- YOU KNOW FOR AT US
SOMETIMES. BUT AND SO- WHICH
AND- DO THE CONTINUING KOPEN
CRIED WE CONTINUE TO
PARTICIPATE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
HE HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM.
AT THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. A FOR THOSE HERE IN
ATTENDANCE- THIS MORNING BOTH A
HUMAN PARTICIPANTS MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC PLEASE KNOW THAT
THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING FACE
COVERINGS ARE REQUIRED TO BE
WORN AT ALL TIMES. PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IT IS EXPECTED TO BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. DUE TO PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THE REQUIREMENTS WILL
FORCE YOU HAVE LIMITED SEATING
AVAILABLE IN THIS ROOM AND WE
WILL BE CAREFULLY MONTEREY
CAPACITY THROUGHOUT THE HERE.
PERSON PRESENTATIONS WE WILL
RECEIVE THIS MORNING SOME
PANELIST. WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
THIS MORNING WILL BE JOINING US
VIA VIDEO CONFERENCE WE WILL
WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENTS BOTH IN
PERSON VIA PHONE TOWARDS THE
END OF THE HEARING. THE PHONE
NUMBER WILL BE ON THE SCREEN
AND POSTED ON THE ASSEMBLY.
COMMITTEE WEBSITE ALL PUBLIC
COMMENTS ARE LIMITED TO TWO
MINUTES PER CALLER. THE PUBLIC
IS ALSO WELCOME TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE OF ITS PUBLIC EMAIL
ADDRESS WHICH YOU CAN FIND ON
OUR WEBSITE. AND PLEASE NOTE
THAT THE HEARING HAS A HARDTO
STOP. TIME OF ELEVEN THIRTY AM
THIS MORNING. TO THE HUMAN CAN
BE CLEARED CLEANED PRIOR TO THE
NEXT HEARINGS FINALLY. LIKE TO
ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO PLEASE
HOLD ANY QUESTIONS UNTIL THE
END OF EACH PANEL AND WITH THAT
YOU KNOW AS I MENTIONED THE
PURPOSE OF THIS INFORMATION
HERE IS TO HAVE A DISCUSSION.
TO LEARN ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FORMER
EQUITY ACT OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
OF THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATIONS
AUTHORED BY OUR FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY IT WAS SIGNED BY
THEN- OUR GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
YOU KNOW SO HERE TODAY WE LOOK
TO EXPLORE THE PROGRESS WE HAVE
MADE AS A STATE TO ADDRESS AND
EQUITIES. FOR FARMERS OF COLOR.
AND HOPE TO GET A SENSE OF THE
WORK WE STILL NEED TO DO. THIS
WORK WE HAVE AHEAD. TO SHORE
FULL ACCESS TO STATE PROGRAMS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AND LAND
ACQUISITIONS FOR A LAND
ACQUISITION FOR ALL OF OUR
STATE'S FARMERS OR ASPIRING
FARMERS. I HISTORICALLY MEMBERS
OF SOCIALLY- AND DISADVANTAGED
GROUPS HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO A
WIDE ASSORTMENT OF
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES IN
AGRICULTURE. INCLUDING BEING
DENIED LAND OWNERSHIP IN THE
EARLY NINETEENTH AND TWENTIETH
CENTURIES. AND MORE RECENTLY
EXPERIENCING SOME DELAYS-
DISPROPORTIONAL- SOME DENIAL
WITH GOVERNMENT LOANS. THE
FARMER EQUITY ACT MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN
CONFRONTING THIS PAST- SOME
DISCRIMINATION SOME OF WHICH
AND- STILL THE- TODAY. IT'S
LEGISLATION CODIFIED THE
DEFINITION OF SOCIALLY- A
DISADVANTAGED GROUP AND
SOCIALLY- A DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS AND ESTABLISH THE CDFA
AS THE COORDINATING AGENCY FOR
SOCIALLY- FOR THE SOCIALLY.
DISADVANTAGED FORMER PROGRAMS
NOW THESE PROGRAMS ARE MEANT TO
BENEFIT FARMERS WHO HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO PASS RACIAL OR
ETHNIC PREJUDICE- FARMERS WHO
ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN- AMERICAN
INDIAN I'M- ALASKAN NATIVE I
THINK HISPANIC. ASIAN AMERICAN
NATIVE HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER. AND THEY BENEFIT
OTHER UNDERSERVED GROUPS OF
FARMERS AS WELL INCLUDING URBAN
FARMERS VETERAN FARMERS WOMEN
FARMERS AND LGBT Q. FARMERS.
THE FARMER EQUITY ACT AIMS TO
EMPOWER FARMERS BY ENSURING
THAT C. D. F. A. INCLUDES
SOCIALLY- SOCIALLY A DISSIDENT
FARMERS AND RANCHERS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT ADOPTION
IMPLEMENTATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF ITS POLICIES AND PROGRAMS.
IT ALSO THAT. TO COORDINATE
EFFORTS AND SHARE INFORMATION
REGARDING SOCIALLY- THE
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA CULTURES THE MOST
DIVERSE IN THE WORLD BOTH IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF THE
COMMODITIES PRODUCED HERE IN
OUR STATE. BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF
THE INCREDIBLY DIVERSE ARRAY OF
FARMERS AND RANCHERS WORKING
HARD TO BRING THOSE COMMODITIES
TO MARKET. THE DIVERSITY- THE
USE OF OUR STATE IS ONE OF OUR
GREATEST TRAINS. AND IS
SOMETHING I BELIEVE STRONGLY
SHOULD BE CELEBRATED IN
SUPPORT. IN ORDER TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE THRIVING
WE MUST CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
THE LONG TERM PROSPERITY OF ALL
OUR CURRENT FARMERS AND
RANCHERS. AND WE MUST DO ALL WE
CAN TO ENCOURAGE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CALIFORNIA'S AND
RANCHERS. AND WE MUST WORK TO
REMOVE A LONG STANDING BARRIERS
TO SERVICE THE RACIAL ETHNIC
PREJUDICE- IT'S NOT ONLY THE
RIGHT THING FOR US TO DO- BUT
IT WILL GO A LONG WAY TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION. TODAY WE'LL HEAR
FROM BOTH FARMERS ADVOCATES AND
ALL OF WHOM HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN FARMING AND FORMER EQUITY
ISSUES. I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
DISCUSSION I DO KNOW THAT IT
DOESN'T MENTION DUE TO A
CONFLICT IN SCHEDULE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ID ARE. CURRY IS MAYBE
WITH US NOW- BUT WILL BE WITH
US VIRTUALLY. A SHE WAS THE
AUTHOR OF THE MENTION OF FARMER
EQUITY ACT SO I INVITE HER IF
SHE HAS ANY COMMENTS TO MAKE
THEM NOW. AND ALSO JOINING US
IN THIS ROOM IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REGGIE JONES SAWYER. CECILIA
ARE YOU THERE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GERMAN APPRECIATE
OPPORTUNITY JUST SAY A FEW
WORDS- IT IS BEEN HONOR FOR ME
TO WORK ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT- FROM DAY ONE WHEN I
WAS APPROACH TO. WORK ON IT-
YEAH IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE ALL OF OUR
FARMERS ARE TAKING CARE OF A
PARTICULAR SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED. WE STILL HAVE A
LOT OF VERY YEARS AHEAD OF US.
SO BEFORE I GO US TO GET
STARTED I WANT TO JUST THINK
EVERYBODY'S WORKED ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT. THE TICKET ONLY
CDFA CAROL BECAUSE- KAREN ROSS
HER TEAM. EVERYONE HAS BEEN
BEHIND BEEN PRETTY GOOD THING
YEAH. I THINK RIGHT NOW IS
REALLY TAKING THIS TO A NEW LOW.
THE LEVEL THAT WE WANTED TO GO
BUT WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO AND I WANT TO JUST ASSURE
HER AND CDFA THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROJECT. YOU KNOW WE STILL HAVE
ISSUES ABOUT THE A OR FOR. OUR
FARMERS WANTING TO GET
ADDITIONAL PLANTS YOU KNOW LAND
IS A BIG. PROBLEM HOME TRYING
TO FIND THE RIGHT. PIECE OF
LAND AND PLAN TO ACTUALLY BE. A
UP. FARMER FRANKLY. WE HAVE
LANGUAGE BERRY WE STILL HAVE.
ACCESS TO AVAILABLE. RESOURCES
TO. SO LAW THESE THE NEXT YEARS
I HOPE WE CONTINUE TO. SO THIS
GROUP IN OUR TO JUST TO GET AT.
THINK YOU FOR THIS TO. OTHERS
NOTHING BETTER. THAN SEEING-
ARE BILLS IMPLEMENTED AND THIS
ONE HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED. OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
AND ACROSS OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT CALIFORNIA'S
DONE. AND IT'S A MAKES YOU FEEL
REALLY GREAT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
THE LEADER IN THIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING THE SPEAKERS TODAY.
AND ALL OF THOSE EITHER
INVOLVED THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE IN THIS SPACE- AND AT THIS
TIME I INVITE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO SHARE
COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER. HI I AM I'M SIMILAR
REGGIE JONES SAWYER REPRESENTS
SOUTH LOS ANGELES. AND IN. IN
MANY WAYS PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK WHY
ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE A CULTURE
COMMITTEE- THERE IS.
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES. AND WE HAVE
INDUSTRY AND ALL SORTS OF.
DIFFERENT M. THERE IN FACT. OF
MY STAFF JUST BRIEF ME ON THE
POULTRY INDUSTRY THAT'S IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH- WE HAVE TWENTY
SITES WHICH YOU KNOW. I KNEW
ABOUT TO BUT. I KNOW ABOUT THE
OTHER EIGHTEEN SO. BEEN THERE
MOST LATINO. AND SO WE NEED TO.
BE TO LET KNOW ABOUT THE TWO.
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN IT NOW
BUT ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T FORGET. THAT AMERICA
BASED ON AGRICULTURE. THE
REASON WE ARE POWERHOUSES
BECAUSE OF AGRICULTURE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WAS BUILT ON
THE BACKS OF FREE LABOR. OR
LABOR THAT. PEOPLE WEREN'T PAID
WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN PAID
AND BECAUSE OF THAT IT IT. NOT
ONLY SUPPORTED THAT ADD
BUSINESS BUT MOST IMPORTANT- IT
CREATE A WELL FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE. BUT NOT NECESSARILY
DISADVANTAGED VOTE. AND SO I
SOMEONE WHO JUST BEEN
REAPPOINTED TO WE JUST BEEN
APPOINTED TO THE NEW.
REPARATIONS TASK FORCE- WE WANT
TO LOOK AT ALL OF THAT YOU
KNOW- I MAY NOT. GET MY FORTY
ACRES AND A MULE- BUT IF I HAD
TO CUT A DEAL YOU CAN KEEP THE
MEAL BUT GIVEN MY FORTY ACRES-
THE SO WE NEED TO HAVE A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT EQUITY. ON
THAT GOES BEYOND JUST WHAT WE
CAN SEE. BUT WHAT THINGS WE
DON'T NECESSARILY SEE UP FRONT.
REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE COME.
AS AN AWARD ANY COMMENTS. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY HERE AT
THE HEARING ON THE BE ON THE
COMMITTEE- I'M A DISTRICT THAT
HAS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
AGRICULTURE SO I ALMOST KIND OF
WONDER HOW I NEVER ENDED UP ON
THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE BUT
BETWEEN WINE GRAPES AND PEARS
AND APPLES AND- GROUP YOU KNOW-
DAIRY CATTLE- HUGE SUSTAINABLE
AG FOOD NETWORK- THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT- AND THAT IS A LOT OF
THIS IS FUELED BY- BY LABOR-
THAT IS- STRUGGLES. TO SAY THE
LEAST THE TIME SO I'M VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO- THE
DISCUSSIONS HERE TODAY AND- HOW
WE CAN- MAKE THINGS BETTER NEXT
MORE EQUITABLE FOR EVERYONE
FANTASTIC WHAT THANK YOU SO THE
NUMBER WHAT. AND WITH THAT OUR
FIRST PANEL WILL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE CDFA IS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FORMER
EQUITY ACT OUR FIRST PANELIST
IS THE A RITTENHOUSE WAS WHO
WAS HIRED BY CDFA THESE ARE AS
SEE A FACE FIRST EVER FORMER
EQUITY ADVISER IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. PRIOR TO HER
TIME AT CFA SHE SPENT HER
ENTIRE CAREER WORKING FOR BOTH
URBAN OR WITH BOTH URBAN AND
RURAL AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TRAINING RESOURCES
FOR BEGINNING AND SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS- SHE CONTINUES TO
MAINTAIN A FARM HERSELF IN YOLO
COUNTY WHERE SHE AND HER
PARTNER. A FORM FIFTEEN ACRES
OF VEGETABLES AND BERRIES AND
CARE FOR A SMALL- ORCHARD SO
MISS RITTENHOUSE. WELCOME AND
IT IS ALL YOURS. GOOD MORNING-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT-
INTRODUCTION TODAY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATED ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
GOT CREEK COMMENT. I'M REALLY
EXCITED TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
AND- BACKGROUND A BIT ON THE
FARM EQUITY REPORT THAT WAS
RELEASED IN TWENTY TWENTY JUNE.
AND THEN- A BIT MORE ABOUT. THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND A REALLY
TALKING ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
THAT LIE AHEAD AND THAT EFFORT
TO TFA HAVE BEEN MAKING- OVER
THE PAST YEAR TO- ADDRESS A
FARMER EQUITY. I'M IN A- SHARE
SCREEN KNOWN. EVERYONE ABLE TO
SEE THAT. NOT YET JUST A BLACK
SCREEN. IT IS THAT WORKING OUT.
NO IT'S STILL A BLACK SCREEN ON
OUR END. THERE WE GO WE CAN.
REMEMBER OKAY. REMOTELY WE THAT.
OKAY REMOTE REMEMBER CONTENT
BUT NOT IN THE- NO IT IS NOT
LIVE NOW- WE CAN SEE HERE IN
THE- THE CHAMBERS. OKAY
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU FOR THAT
GREAT INTER ON THE FARMER
EQUITY ACT ITSELF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHT PASSED IN TWO SEVENTEEN
WITH THE SUPPORT OF MANY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND ONE IN PARTICULAR THAT
CALIFORNIA FORMER JUSTICE
COLLABORATIVE THAT HAS WORKED
ON TIRELESSLY BOTH TO IMPLEMENT
THAT LEGISLATION AND THEN TO-
CONTINUED. HAVE DISCUSSIONS
AND- WORK WITH MYSELF AND CDFA
TO ENSURE THAT THE COMPONENTS.
OF THAT ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED.
I'M GOING. TO THE- THIRD HERE
WITH ASSEMBLY SICK OF FACT
ABOUT WHAT THE MOST RECENT
ADVANCES HAS SHOWN ABOUT
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND RANCHERS IN CALIFORNIA-
NEARLY ONE IN FIVE. OR 19%
APPROXIMATELY ARE SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AN APARTMENT
APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION ACRES. AND ALSO ROUGHLY
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND- FARMERS
AND RANCHERS. INVESTORS THESE
ARE THE MOST RECENT STATISTICS
FROM THE AGCENTER WHICH ARE
REALLY CONSIDERED MORE OF LIKE
A BASELINE DATA INFORMATION
BECAUSE IT REALLY DOESN'T
ACCURATELY CAPTURE URBAN
FARMING- OR AGRICULTURE THAT
PRACTICE THERE AND IT REALLY
IS- A CUMBERSOME. THE SURVEY TO
FILL OUT A SURVEY IS ALWAYS
CONSIDERED TO BE A BASE DAY-
FOR WHAT ACTUALLY MY BE IN THE
STATE OF. BUT IT IS THE MOST
REAL AND- SET OF DATA THAT
EXISTS TWO UNDERSTAND THE
DEMOGRAPHICS- OF THAT. SOCIALLY
THAT THE FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
IN THE STATE AND THEN ALL
NATION. OFFICIALLY DISOBEY
FARMERS AND RANCHERS ARE
LOCATED IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
HIGHEST NUMBERS ARE FOUND IN
THE SAN DIEGO FRESNO STANISLAUS
TULARE IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY- AND
I COMMEND. THERE'S REAL STILL A
NEED FOR MORE COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE DATA ON THAT THE
GROUPS OF FARMERS PRACTICING.
IN WITHIN URBAN AREAS. I'M
GOING TO BRIEFLY TALK THIS
MORNING ABOUT THE FARMER EQUITY
REPORT THAT WAS RELEASED IN
JUNE- AND GO OVER THE THEMES
AND RECOMMENDATIONS AND REALLY
WHAT IT'S BEING BUILT FROM
THAT. REPORT THE REPORT WAS-
YOU KNOW PART OF THE AB
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
LEGISLATION AND WHEN I STARTED
WORKING AT CDFA IN THE FALL OF
TWO TWENTY EIGHTEEN. I PRETTY
MUCH SPENT MOST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN A DEVELOPING AND
RESEARCHING FOR THIS REPORT.
THIS IS ALL PRE CODED ON SO I
WAS THANKFULLY ABLE TO GO AND
VISIT FARMERS AND RANCHERS. I'M
ACROSS THE STATE. AND MY GOAL
REALLY I WAS. ENSURE THAT THE
VOICE OF THESE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS DURING IN TRIP. AND
THAT THEIR STORIES WERE HIGHLY.
AS THE WAY TO SHOW THEIR
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTION ALSO TO
REALLY UNDERLYING THERE'S-
CONTINUED. AND THEIR CONTINUED-
STRUGGLE TO ACTUALLY RUN THEIR
BUSINESSES. I'M AND HOW HIS-
INEQUITIES AND ANY COURT
ACTIONS HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
MAKING THEIR- BUSINESSES-
DIFFICULT TO RUN AND BE
SUCCESSFUL IN SOME CASES. AND
SO YOU'LL SEE PICTURES OF THESE
FARMERS AND RANCHERS THE ROUTE
WITHIN THE REPORT IS ALSO VERY
THEIR ACTUAL STORIES AND
THEY'RE LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS-
THAT THEY REPRESENT WHERE THEIR
FARMING AND- I INTERVIEWED
THIRTY THREE FARMERS. AND FOR
THIS REPORT AND THEY WERE
FARMERS FROM. BOTH URBAN AND
RURAL AREAS THE REPRESENTED
CROPS FROM ANYWHERE- STONE
FRUIT NOT. I CANNABIS GROWERS
L. CUT FLOWERS NOT TRUE DROP.
MANY PERSONALIZED AGRICOLE
OPERATION- AND IN FROM A OR AN
EIGHT EVEN IN EIGHT SEVEN ONE
OPERATE UP TO THREE HUNDRED
ACRES TO TRY TO CAPTURE THE
REAL DIVERSITY IN THE ACTUAL
TYPES OF AGRICULTURE BEING
PRACTICED HERE- BY THESE GROUPS
OF FARMERS AND RANCHERS. THE
FIRST- THE FIRST CHANNEL THAT
WAS. REALLY BROUGHT ABOUT IT BY
THE REPORT AND CONTINUE TO BE
SOMETHING OF GREAT AND- IS LESS
TENURE AND WE IT'S ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED IN THE IN BUT MANY
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
DO NOT HAVE STABLE LONG TERM
ARRANGEMENTS FOR THE LAND THAT
THEY FARM AND THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT TO. UNDERSTAND AND-
DOES THE STRUGGLES THAT MANY
FARMERS AND RANCHERS HAVE IN
THE STATE ACTUALLY- TO HAVE A
LONG TERM LEASE. ON TEN OF THE
FIFTEEN APARTMENTS ABOUT EIGHT
OR HAD TO MOVE THEIR
OPERATIONAL LEAST ONE. IT WOULD
TO EITHER A RENT INCREASE A
LEASE TERMINATION OR OTHER
NATURAL RESOURCE DOCTOR LACK OF
WATER- FIRE FLOOD OR DROUGHT.
75% WERE UNSURE IF THEY WOULD
OPERATE UNDER THE SAME LEASE
EVEN AFTER THE TWENTY NINETEEN
GROWING SEASON- IN MANY OTHERS-
WE'RE UNSURE IF THEY WOULD
CONTINUE- EVEN BEING ABLE TO
OPERATE THEY'RE BOTH CROPS THAT
THEY OFFERED NOW IF THEY HAVE
ANY IMPLICATIONS FOR THINGS
LIKE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS- AND
THERE'S SO MANY MORE EXAMPLES.
WHERE LAND TENURE- IS A BARRIER
FOR AT APPLICATION FOR GRANT
PROGRAMS AND OTHER THINGS THAT-
THAT CDFA NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE TAKING THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AS WELL AND AS A
FAMILY MEMBER YOUR CREE NOTED-
AT LEAST TENURE TO BE SOME THAT-
IS WORKING ON- IN THE REPORT I
TALKED ABOUT. IN INTERAGENCY.
TO REALLY START TO- DEVELOP
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
TO PUT EITHER PURCHASE PLANS
HAVE ACCESS TO FARMLAND ENSURE
STABLE LAND LEASES AND ALL TO
IMPLEMENT CONSERVATION
PRACTICES. THOSE THREE THINGS.
THE FAA YEAH IN THE PARA BEEN-
WE TO ENSURE THE GRANT THAT WE
DO FOR. AND RANCHERS ARE
WORKING TO MODIFY PROGRAMS TO
IT- MAKE SURE THAT LAND CAN YOU
IS NOT A BIG AT YOUR PARKED AT
THE- WE'VE ALSO BEEN- CALL.
CLOSELY THE DEATH OF CUTS. I'M
OUT THERE WITH THEIR WORK. AT
PRESS PRO PRIORITIES FOR THE
FIFTEEN ADLAI CON PROGRAM. BUT
THERE'S NEEDS TO- HAVE MORE
HUNGER. WITH OTHER AGENCY AND
OTHER- ELECTED IF ABOUT- DID TO
LAND AT AND IT IS THE- KNOWN
FACT THAT FARMERS ARE THE
COUNTRY. ARE GETTING OLDER AND-
RICH HI AND THERE- HELLO OF
OPPORTUNITY BACK BE REALIZED ON
TO RECALL. AND SO THE SYSTEM
THAT- CONTINUE TO BE IN A IS
AND- IN TWENTY TWO ONE HOPE TO
MORE. MOVEMENT ON. IT IS. ONE
SEEM- THE SECOND CHALLENGE LINK
THOUGH ON MY SEEM YOU KNOW
EVERYONE ON THAT THERE'S NO
LANGUAGE SPOKEN HERE AND CAL
BUT IN ACTION. IT IS THE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT FORMER FINANCE
DO NOT ALWAYS SPEAK ENGLISH IS
THE FOR LANGUAGE AND THAT THEY
PROHIBITIVE WHEN YOU UNDER IN
ABOUT THEIR ABOUT RAY. ABOUT
KROGER ABOUT. MARKETING
PRODUCTS HAVE MANAGE BUSINESS
MANAGER. AND ALSO COME THROUGH
THERE LAW OF CALM WITH THINK IN-
MEETING- IN AND POP SPACE.
WINDOWS MEANING ARE A ENGLISH
READ THAN ALLOWING THAT. FILM
COMFORTABLE COME AND- TWENTY
SEVEN THE THIRTY FARM THAT THAT
I INTERVIEWED SPEAK ENGLISH AS
THEIR FOR LANGUAGE. AND TWENTY
SIX OF THE TWO SEVEN. GENERATE
AND WITH- NO FOR LANGUAGE
AFRICAN. IN THE- AGAIN THE WAS
WRITTEN WITH CO GOOD NIGHT AT
BEFORE WE- MOVING TO. A LOT
MORE FOR. PUBLIC MEETINGS AND
INNER- BUT- WITHIN THE WITHIN
TWO- WE HAVE DONE MADE SIMPLE
ON OFFERING- AGENCY WHY
OPPORTUNITIES INTERPRETATION
WE'RE DOING A PILOT PROJECT
WITH OUR STATE BOARD TO OFFER-
SIMULTANEOUS INTERPRETATION
INTO SPANISH- THERE ARE LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS THE MOVING PIECES
ABOUT OFFER YOU KNOW
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCORPORATE
TRANSLATION INTO VIRTUAL
MEETING SPACES- CERTAINLY
WITHIN PDF. OFFERING CHU
OPPORTUNITIES AND- I RESOURCES
FOR DOES EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
INTERACTING DIRECTLY WITH
FARMERS AND RANCHERS AS WELL-
BUT THERE'S STILL A NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND ENHANCE
OUR INFORMATION AND SERVICES IN
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH-
STARTING WITH OUR- YOU KNOW OUR
WEBSITE OUR PRESS RELEASES ARE
NARAL TRANSLATED INTO SPANISH.
AND WE'RE WORKING ON OFFERING
OTHER- OTHER PUBLIC INFORMATION
IT AND BANISHES WELL AND THEN
REALLY- DID. A LANGUAGE OUT
REACHED WITH SOMETHING THAT
CAME ABOUT A LOT DURING KOBE
NINETEEN WHEN MANY GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES WERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET INFORMATION TO
THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEEDED IT
THE MOST REGARDING TESTING- AND
NOT VACCINES AND YOU KNOW
DEVELOPING. RELATE WITH. JIMMY
OR THAT OTHERS- AND- REQUIRING.
SKILLS NEW EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
WORKING ON THE GROUND- WITH THE
FARMERS AND RANCHERS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A PRIORITY I'M
GOING FORWARD. THE THIRD THING
THAT I'D LIKE TO MENTION IS
ENGAGEMENT WITH AG INDUSTRY AND
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS AND
THAT'S REALLY GET TO- A BIG
PIECE OF EQUITY AND THAT IS
ACCESS TO INFORMATION AND THE
LAST TWO CHALLENGES HERE THAT
I'LL TALK ABOUT A REALLY ABOUT
ACCESS TO INFORMATION AND USED.
TO STRUCTURE- THAT EXIST STILL
THAT YOU'RE NOT THIRD ALL OF
THE FARMERS AND RANCHERS THAT
WERE THAT WERE AT TRYING TO
REACH SERVE AS AN AGING. SO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS THAT MANY
SOCIAL FARMERS ARE RANCHERS DO
NOT BELONG TO IN THIS
ORGANIZATION- AND THEY DO NOT-
THAT DOES THEY DON'T ABOUT
PROGRAM THEY HEAR ABOUT IN PART
AND READ AND OTHER ON. EIGHTY
FIVE OF THOSE I INTERVIEWED
SAID THEY DID NOT ATTEND
MEETINGS BECAUSE THEY DID IT
THE MEETINGS ACTUALLY APPLIED
TO THEM. IT PERCENT SAID DID
NOT RAISE HE ABOUT OR THEY WERE
AT HIGH WHEN THEY WERE WORKING
ON THE FARM. FIFTY FIVE PER SAY
THAT THEY DID NOT JOINING. OR
CLUB GROUP THEY DID. HAVE
ENJOYING THE GROUP. AND YOU CAN
SEE HOW THE- PLAYS A PART IN
THE ACTION BOY. OF THE
HISTORICALLY UNDER GROUP.
NUMBER ONE THERE'S NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH THEM
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT PRESENT AT
THE MEETING OR THE INFORMATION
OR THEY DON'T LOOK AT THE
INTERNET SITE THAT HAS THE
INFORMATION ABOUT PUBLIC
MEETINGS- AND THAT THEY DON'T
FEEL THAT IT APPLIES TO HIM
THEY'RE BUSY THEY'RE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE TIME TO
ATTEND- NEEDING ABOUT
REGULATIONS THAT MIGHT AFFECT
THEIR FORM OR JOIN A BOARD OR
COMMISSION THAT- CREATE
POLICIES THAT MIGHT AFFECT
THEIR FARM AND SO THIS IS A
BIG- IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
FARMER EQUITY ACT. AND IT. GOES
TO REALLY LOOK AT SHIFTING THE
WAY THAT OUR AGENT. DOES
BUSINESS AND DOES OUTREACH- TO
SERVE- AND GET THE PROBE FROM.
TO THE GROUP'S THAT HAVE BEEN
THE MOST IMPACTED HISTORICALLY
AND CURRENTLY- AND THAT WHO
NEED THIS INFORMATION THE MOST.
THE ONES WHO REALLY DO NEED THE
GRANT PROGRAMS OR NEED THOSE
CONSERVATION. ON THEIR FARMS
AND REALLY- ARE BEING SERVED
BY- BY THE PROGRAM- IF YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR NEXT- FROM BROUGH
AND MY WHO ARE COOPER EXT GA
SPECIALIST AND- I JUST. IN THE
REPORT I CAN'T ENOUGH ABOUT THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING RIGHT
NOW AND I'LL LET THEM SPEAK
ABOUT WHAT. YOU'RE DOING WITH-
UNDERSERVED FARMERS. BUT THE
REAL NEED HERE IS TO SUPPORT
EXISTING ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE
TRUSTED RELATIONSHIPS. WITH
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND RANCHERS ARE OUT OF REACH
CAN'T REALLY BE DONE FROM
SACRAMENTO AND IF WE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO HAVE STAFF
STATEWIDE WE'RE WE REALLY NEED
TO FOCUS ON SUPPORTING THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE- TO HAVE
THOSE TRED TO RELEASE- WHO WHO
ARE ABLE. TO HELP THOSE- AND-
THAT REALLY FOCUSING ON OUR
REGION. CREATED WITH AND BY
FARMERS OF COLOR AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR LED ORGANIZATION FROM THE
BEGINNING AND NOT AS AN
AFTERTHOUGHT- IS ALSO IMPORTANT
POINT OF THIS. ONE THING THAT
HAS COME OUT OF THIS
RECOMMENDATION IS- TO BCPS-
EIGHT AM ONE BCK WITH PROBE IN-
THAT HOPE TO ALL OF YOU HAVE
SEEN- BUT INTO IT IS- AT THE-
FOR SMALL FARMS- THE SMALL BAR
PROGRAM THAT YOU SEE COOPER
EXTENSION BUT ALL. THE I T. A.
ORGANISING. THAT ARE HAVE BEEN
A DO THINK IN THROUGHOUT TWENTY
TO HELP THEM APPLY. AFTER
RELEASED FUND AND THAT WHO
REALLY NEED ADDITION SUPPORT TO
ACT HELP THOSE FARMER DIRECTLY.
AND THEN THE LAST PIECE HERE IS
TO RE. AND PROGRAM AND MANY
RICH LATEST EVENT THEIR
INSURANCE NOT ONLY FOR MIL. I'M
WITH THE RESORT TECH ASSIST AND
OTHER INFORMATION BECAUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW IT EXISTS OR THEY
DON'T THE TIME WILL RETURN TO
APPLY IT WILL BE DONE NOW THIS
IS ALSO A GOOD- RELATED TO
FUNDING OR SOME. TA ORGANISER
TO HELP- DOES HELP BOTH THREE
DIRECTLY. I WE A COUPLE EXAM OF
HOW THAT BEEN IMPLEMENTED IT
CDFA. WITH BOTH OUR CLIMATE
SMART AND KEY TO ARE ON THE
GROUND IN ABLE TO HELP. OUR
FARMERS AND APPLY FOR OUR-
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE. WE
ALSO HAVE. A PROTEGER FRESH
THAT ARE ALL DOING VERY SIMILAR.
AFTER TWO TO ENGAGE WITH
FARMERS- AND FROM EDUCATIONAL
READ THAT FOR. A RELATED THE
FOOD STATE MY- ACT- AND THEN
ALL AS AN THE THAT B. C. P. R.
WE- THAT WE SUBMITTED OUR- ALSO
REALLY FOCUSES ON THAT- BEING A
TO HELP FARMERS AND RANCHERS
TO. FROM HAVE THAT. RELATED TO
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND. DO YOU
THINK THAT THAT CONCLUSION.
WORKING FOR AND REAL FOCUS ON
TWENTY THIRTY ONE AS THE NUMBER.
THAT WOULD MAYBE DIDN'T THEY OF
REALLY GETTING IT THE CAR WITH
THE ACT AND HAPPY. AND
PRIORITIZING- THESE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS WHO NEED TO BOTH GUIDE
AND SHAPE AND LEAD THE PROGRAM
I'M SO THAT THEY ACTUALLY WILL
WORK FOR THOSE GROUPS- SO I'D
FORMED AD HOC ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ONE COMPRISED- OF BY
PARK FARMERS AND RANCHERS FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE I WE HAD OUR
FIRST MEETING THIS WEEK AND-
HOW TO A SMALL FARMS SUPPORT
ORGANIZATION GROUP AGAIN
ORGANIZATIONS ARE DIRECTLY
SUPPORTING SUPPORTING SMALL
FARMS TO HELP THEM WITH
ECONOMIC RELIEF- EFFORTS.
ADDITIONALLY INTERNALLY- OUR
OUR AGENCY IS A PART OF THE
CAPITAL COLLABORATIVE ON RACE
AND EQUITY WHICH IS A GROUP OF.
FIFTEEN DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES PARTICIPATING IN A
RACIAL EQUITY TRAINING YEAR
LONG TRAINING- AT THE END ABOUT
WILL HAVE A RACIAL EQUITY
ACTION PLAN FOR AGENCY. SEVERAL
OTHER AGENCIES HAVE ALSO HAVE
BEEN PARTICIPATING IN THIS
COHORT AND ALREADY HAVE PUBLIC
RACIAL EQUITY ACTION PLAN ON
SUCH AS THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL- AND OTHERS. AND YOU
CAN REALLY START TO SEE THE
MOMENTUM THAT'S BUILDING AMONG
OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO
ADDRESS- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TRAINING EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
INTERNALLY- WITHIN OUR STAFF AS
WELL AS OUR ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS THE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS TO CALIFORNIA. AND
THEN WE'LL ALSO BE DOING WE
HAVE A RACIAL EQUITY SPEAKER
SERIES ALSO INTERNALLY FOR ALL
OF OUR STAFF AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES. ON SUCH AS THE
P. E. I. COMMITTEE TO ENGAGE-
ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WELL
IN THIS EFFORT- RELATED TO IT.
RELATED TO INCLUDE THE
INCREASING ACCESS TO OUR GRANT
PROGRAM- AS A PRIORITY FOR THE
SPECIALTY CROP BLOCK GRANT I'M
REALLY THROUGHOUT TWENTY
NINETEEN NOTING THAT THERE'S
STILL A NEED TO RESHAPE THE
PRIORITY FOR FIRST TIME
APPLICANTS FOR REALLY UNDER
THIRD AND THAT MORE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO DON'T HAVE
PAID GREAT WRITERS TO ACTUALLY
ACT WITH AND GET ONE ON ONE
ASSISTANCE LONGER TERM
ASSISTANCE ON TO HELP MAKE
THESE GRANTS MORE EQUITABLE-
AND ACCESSIBLE WE'VE HIRED A
FARM EQUITY AND OUT ANALYST WHO
WILL BE IN THE GRANT OFFICE AND
SHE IS. THE TYPICALLY- TASKED
WITH WORKING WITH ME AND WITHIN
THE GRANT OFFICE TO HELP-
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT FOR
THOSE. APPLYING FOR THE
SPECIALTY CROP BLOCK GRANT-
JUST NOTE AGAIN THE IMPORTANT
OF OUR GOING COMMUNITY- WITH
THE SUPPORTERS OF AB THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT THE AUTHORS AND
THAT THE SUPPORT ORGANIZATION.
ON GOING COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BAR REJECTED
COLLABORATIVE WHO ARE MADE UP
OF. MANY INDIVIDUALS AND GROUPS
THAT HAVE MANY OTHER ROLES THAT
THEY PLAY- SERVING HAVE
FARMERS- THE SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AND HAVING ONGOING
MEETINGS WITH THEM- GETTING
THEIR GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT IT
IN QUITE AS- REALLY- I'M
IMPORTANT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN- AND THEN FINALLY- THERE
ARE NEW WEBSITE RESOURCES ON
OUR ON OUR- UNDERSTOOD IF THEY
WANTED ALL SHARE HERE. THE
FIRST WE I CREATED BACK IN
TWENTY NINETEEN IT IS AN INDEX
SORRY THIS IS ALL RELATED AGAIN
TO ACCESS TO INFORMATION. BUT
ALSO FARMER CENTRIC INFORMATION
INFORMATION THAT IS THE
RELATIVE TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AND HOPEFULLY SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS- SO THAT THEY CAN AVE
BETTER ACCESS TO INFORMATION
AND RESOURCES- WE HAVE A
TWITTER ACCOUNT NOW IN SPANISH-
WE AGAIN LIKE I SAID WE'RE
OFFERING OUR- PRESS RELEASES IN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH AS WELL. OF
THE PHARMACY THE COURTS PORTAL
AT THE TOP HERE IS. JUST A
REORGANIZATION OF ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT OUR WEBSITE THAT
ARE ACTUALLY RELATIVE TO
FARMERS THE NEW PRIMARILY
INCLUDE GRANT PROGRAMS BUT ALSO
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
REGULATIONS AND OTHER-
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT CONGRESS
MIGHT NEED TO KNOW. AND THEN
FINALLY SOMETHING THAT WE JUST
MADE PUBLIC. IS AN INDEX OF ALL
OF OUR BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
ANOTHER PIECE OF THE FARMER
EQUITY REPORT THAT IT DIDN'T GO
INTO A LOT THIS MORNING BUT IS
A VERY IMPORTANT. COMPONENT OF
ACCESS IS THAT MANY OF OUR
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS. I DON'T
HAVE- REPRESENTATIVES OF
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED GROUPS.
AND THIS. NOT ONLY THAT THAT
ARE ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS AND TASK
FORCES. HAVE SEPARATE PIECES OF
INFORMATION BUT IT WASN'T ALL.
AND CONSISTENT AND IT WAS AN
ALL IN ONE PLACE SO THAT THEY
ACTUALLY PUT ALL THE
INFORMATION ONE PLACE. SHARE
THE COST ALL GROUPS. A MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC CAN EASILY GO AND
FIND INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO
JOIN- YOU THESE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS WHAT ARE YOU WHAT
ARE THE EXPECTATIONS
EXTRATERRESTRIAL THAT'S AN ON
GOING PROJECT- AND HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP THAT- SO.
ALL THE THINGS. THAT REALLY YOU
KNOW RELATED TO THE FAR. REPORT
WHAT WE'RE REALLY JUST GETTING
STARTED THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE YOU CAN WILL
CONTINUE TO DO. WITH THE
SUPPORT OF EVERYONE INVOLVED IN
PARTICULARLY- THE- ENGAGEMENT
AND- INCLUSION OF. AS MANY OF
THE FARMERS OF COLORED. THEY
HAVE BEEN THE MOST AFFECTED
BOTH BY CULVERTED AND BY BY ALL
OF THESE OTHER HISTORIC AND
INSTITUTIONAL- INEQUITIES. AND
REALLY LET THEM GUIDE AND SHAPE
THESE PROGRAMS AND POLICIES
GOING FORWARD. IT'S GREAT-
MISPRINT HOUSE REALLY
APPRECIATE- ALL THE INFORMATION
OKAY HOLD ON AS WE MAY HAVE
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF THE
PANEL- OUR NEXT PANELIST IS
RUTH- DAHLQUIST WILLARD- IS HE
SHE'S A- SMALL FARMS AND- CROPS
ADVISOR FOR UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION IN FRESNO AND- TULARE
COUNTIES. WHERE SHE SERVES A
DIVERSE CLIENTELE INCLUDING
SMALL SCALE FAMILY FARMS
BEGINNING FARMERS IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE FARMERS INCLUDING AMONG
IN OTHER SOUTHEAST ASIAN
FARMERS. SHE ALSO ASSIST
FARMERS WITH A WHAT WIDE ARRAY
OF SPECIALTY CROPS THAT I
CERTAINLY DIDN'T KNOW WERE
GROWN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
INCLUDING ASIAN VEGETABLES
HERBS. TO JU JU BEES MORINGA
BLUEBERRIES STRAWBERRIES
BLACKBERRIES AND I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF VISITING A LONG
FORM- IN THE COUNTY FRESNO.
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA IT'S A GREAT
EXPERIENCE INCESSANTLY FOX SAW
SAW FIRST HAND- THE EXAMPLE OF-
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THE- THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT'S PROVIDED TO
THESE- THESE DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS BUT ALSO THE DIVERSITY
OF THE CROPS THAT WERE GROWN IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. SO WITH
THAT- RUTH WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING WITH US IT'S ALL YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR IT
WRITING AND MICHAEL TO SPEAK
TODAY AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR
COMING TO FRESNO FOR ABOUT IS
IT- THANKS AGAIN FOR GIVING OUT
OVER VIEW OF THE FORMER EQUITY-
ACTS AND THE EFFORTS THAT CDFA
IS WORKING ON- AND- GIVES A
SORT OF A- AN OVERVIEW OF THE
WORK THAT. WE HANG AND I ARE
DOING- AND HOPEFULLY WITH. THE
IDEA THAT- WE CAN SPARK IDEAS
OF HOW TO CONNECTS TO OUR WORK
AND TO NONPROFIT PARTNERS AND
AGENCIES TO. REALLY INCREASE
EQUITY FOR THE FARMERS THAT WE
SERVE- SO I'M ONE OF FOUR SMALL
PROVIDERS IF YOU SEE AN ART
THAT ARE SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND OUR EXTENSION
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY BEEN FOCUS ON
EQUITY FROM THE BEGINNING SINCE
THE ORIGINAL SMALL FAR PROGRAM
WAS STARTED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE AFTER SIMILAR DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT EQUITY- AND THE FIRST
YEAR WAS ALL FORMS OF VISORS
THAT WERE HEARD WORLD BILINGUAL
IN SPANISH AND SMOKERS ON- ON
SPANISH SPEAKING FARMERS AND
SO. ALTHOUGH WE DON'T ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT STATEWIDE PROGRAM
ANYMORE WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
SMALL SCALE FARMERS IN THE
COUNTIES THAT WE WORK AND-
OBVIOUSLY AND PARTICULARLY WITH
A FOCUS ON SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS SO. I
LIKE TO QUICKLY MENTION MYSELF
FROM COLLEAGUES- APARNA
CONSUMER WHO SUPPORTS- CHINESE
IMMIGRANT FARMERS IN THE CENTER
AREA. AND THEN MARGARET LLOYD
IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA HE'S
EXPERT AND STANDING THE OUTRAGE
OF HER PROGRAMS IN SOUTHEAST
ASIAN FARMERS AND WE HAVE. A
LOCAL IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY- WHO
HAS WORKED WITH YOU KNOW
FARMERS AND DEVELOPING
EXTENSION MATERIALS IN SPANISH-
AND I'M LOCATED- IN FRESNO
SORRY COUNTIES AND SALAS DOLLY
WHICH IS ALSO WHERE I GREW UP-
I ACTUALLY HAD THE HONOR TO
RACINE TO SMALL FIRMS ADVISORS
WHO RETIRED AROUND TWENTY
THIRTEEN. AND THAT WHAT WAS
RICHARD MOLINAR IN FRESNO
COUNTY AND MANY OF NECESSARY
COUNTY WHO'S ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL- ADVISORS HIRED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. NINE
BOTH OF THEM HAD THESE
INCREDIBLE LIKE LEGACIES WITH
DECADES OF WORK- SUPPORTING
SMALL SCALE IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE FARMERS. AND THEN I
ALSO HAVE THE HONOR OF WORKING
WITH MICHAEL YANKEL YOU'LL HEAR
FROM NEXT- WHO HAS BEEN
SUPPORTING SOUTHEAST ASIAN
FARMING COMMUNITY FOR TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS NOW INCLUDING- FONG
AND- LOUD TIE. CAMBODIAN AND
VIETNAMESE FARMERS- SO ARE
SERVES OF LARGE OF FOR OF COLOR
OR IN OUR- IN THE WAY U. S.
SENSE RECORDS THERE WERE ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE AND SMALL AND
SOCIALLY FARMERS- THAT'S
DEFINED AS UNDER OF DOLLARS I'M
SORRY HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY ARE BASED THE CENSUS
DATA IN THOSE TWO COUNTIES
COMBINED AS THE INVENTION THAT
NUMBER IS VERY LIKELY UNDER
REPORTED- SO THAT'S A BASS LINE
AND AT LEAST THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED SMALL SCALE SYSTEMS
FARMERS AND BUT YOU COUNTY- AND
ALSO AS YOU MENTIONED LANGUAGE
OFTEN A BARRIER. TO ACCESS
RESOURCES. MOST OF OUR TRAINS
ARE BILINGUAL. IN EITHER MOM OR
SPANISH AND THEN WE ALSO OFFER
INDIVIDUAL SUPPORT FOR
EXTENSION IN WELLINGTON JABI.
AND MICHAEL HAS FOR MANY YEARS
HOSTED A WEEKLY RADIO SHOW IN
MONICA. **** THAT COMMUNITY
ACTUALLY FROM BAKER SEALED UP
TO MODESTO AND IS NOTBEING-
EXPENSES OF THE TO THE
SACRAMENTO AREA WITH MARKET
WAGE WORK- SO IN IN MY TO
COUNTIES WE LOG OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED. INDIVIDUAL FORMER
CONTACTS YEAR YOUR WORKSHOPS
AND THEN OUR ONE ON ONE
SUPPORT- SUCH AS VISITING FARMS
AND ABOUT 85% OF THOSE CONTACT
SERVICE MEMBERS OF COLOR. I
SHOULD ALSO MENTION THAT
PROBABLY HALF OF THOSE CONTACTS
ARE FARMERS THAT CALL MICHAEL
YOUNG FOR ASSISTANCE SO YOU'LL
HEAR MORE. ABOUT THAT NEXT FOR
MICHAEL- SO WHEN I THE WAYS
THAT WE- SCALE FARMERS OF COLOR
IS THROUGH ASSISTANCE AND
PRODUCTION AND MARKETING FOR.
THE SMALLER ACREAGE CROPS THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS MENTIONED
THAT AREN'T I'M NOT SUPPORTED
BY COUNTY BOARDS- SO WE PROVIDE
THAT TYPE OF SUPPORT- FOR
EXAMPLE IN FRESNO COUNTY WE
HAVE A VERY LARGE RADIUS OF THE
ASIAN SPECIALTY VEGETABLES. IS
ACTUALLY INDUSTRY WITH ANNUAL
SALES OF ABOUT. SEVENTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR SO
ALTHOUGH IT'S SMALL FARMS IT
ADDS UP TO. A SUBSTANTIAL-
INDUSTRY AND ITS OWN. AND SO WE
PROVIDE SUPPORT WITH PRODUCTION
ISSUES LIKE PEST MANAGEMENT
NUTRIENT MANAGEMENT YOUR
KITCHEN AS WELL AS DOING SOME
RESEARCH ON THOSE CROPS- FOR
EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW- ACCORDING.
TO WHAT I ARE DOING RESEARCH ON.
TAKE IN CROPS LIKE LEMON GRASS
SOCK CHOICE- WHICH CHIMES
MORINGA AND CHRYSANTHEMUM
LEAVES. BECAUSE THIS
INFORMATION ACTUALLY EXIST FOR
THESE CROPS ALTHOUGH IT'S
NEEDED THOSE FOR FERTILIZER
RECOGNITIONS AND ALSO FOR OUR-
REQUIRE NITROGEN REPORTING FOR
THE IRRIGATED LANDS REGULATORY
PROGRAM. AND SPEAKING OF THAT
PROGRAM I WOULD SAY ONE OF THE
MAJOR THEMES OF OUR WORK HAS
BEEN REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AND-
PROBABLY ALMOST ALL REGULATORY
PROGRAMS ARE JUST NOT REALLY
DESIGNED TO BE A GOOD FIT. FOR
FARMS THAT ARE SMALLER SCALE
AND HIGHLY DIVERSIFIED WITH
ROTATIONS OF MANY DIFFERENT
CROPS- AND CERTAINLY NOT FOR
FARMERS WHO WERE CRIPPLING.
BILINGUAL SUPPORT. I'M SO ONE
OF THE AREAS THAT WE WERE ON A
LOT IS HELPING FARMERS MEANING
COMPLIANCE WITH LOW BRING.
PROGRAMS AND I REALLY TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
MICHAEL'S WORK AND HIS LONG
TERM TRUSTED RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE SOUTHEAST ASIA FROM
COMMUNITY. BASICALLY ANYTIME
AND FARMERS TO GET PAPERWORK IN
THE MAIL THAT. IS A REGULATORY
PROGRAM AFTER TO DO IT. THEY
BRING TO MICHAEL AND HE HELPS
THEM FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESOLVE
IT AND NOT GET COULD BE FOOD
SAFETY THAT YOUR DATA PLANS. TO
REPORTING. LABOR REQUIREMENTS
PERMITS AND REPORTING FOR
PESTICIDE USE AND NOW- SO. THIS
IS DANA GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT
ACT STARTING TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT MAJOR
CHALLENGES FOR SMALL SCALE AND
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY- AND THEN
ON THE OTHER SIDE IS PROGRAMS
WE ALSO ARE INVOLVED IN
COMMUNICATING WITH POLICYMAKERS
ABOUT THOSE CHALLENGES. AND
HOPEFULLY FINDING WAYS TO
IMPROVE THEM SO THEY'RE NOT
JUST ONE SIZE FITS ALL AND THEY
CAN BE ADAPTED TO. THE REALITY
OTHER FARMS- A FEW YEARS AGO WE
WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO SUGGEST
SOME CHANGES TO THE IRRIGATED
LANDS PROGRAM THAT WERE
ADOPTED- TO ALLOW ALTERNATE
NIGER REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FOR SMALL AND DIVERSIFIED
FARMS. AND THEN AND WE DO WORK
CLOSELY WITH CFA AS WELL WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR SOME
OF THE CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS LIKE SWEET
AND HEALTHY SOILS. AS WELL AS
THE DEVELOPING PROGRAMS OR FOOD
SAFETY INSPECTIONS AND WAS VERY
THANKFUL TO HAVE OPEN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE- AND
WITH. CITY BASED PROGRAMS I.
REGARDING EQUITY IN ACCESS
ISSUES- ONE OTHER THING I
REALLY LIKE TO. ABOUT ARMS OUR
SMALL FARMS. IS THAT. WHERE
WE'RE LOCATED WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO LEVERAGE RESOURCES
FOR ACROSS AN ARC. AND EVEN THE
WIDER UC SYSTEM TO BENEFIT
FARMERS THAT WOULDN'T OTHERWISE
BE ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
RESOURCES SO WE KIND OF SERVE
AS A RESOURCE HUB. IN OUR
REGIONS AND WE BRING IN OTHER
IN OUR CAR OFFICERS WHO
SPECIALIZE IN A PARTICULAR
PROPERTY OR DISCIPLINE LIKE
COST MANAGEMENT OR SOCIAL.
SCIENCE SO THAT THEIR EXPERTISE
CAN ALSO BE SENT TO PURSUE BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED URBAN
MIGHT NOT OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT RESOURCE AND- SO
MANY PEOPLE ABOUT. MY PROGRAM
HAS BEEN ABLE TO PURCHASE A
COMPOST SPREADER THAT WE- MAKE
AVAILABLE TO FARMERS TO.
IMPLEMENT. THOSE PROJECTS. YEAH
BECAUSE OF OUR USED RESEARCH AS
WE TO STORE IN THE CURRENT.
WERE THERE TECHNICAL STAFF THAT
MAINTENANCE. AND THEN WE
COLLABORATE WITH BRENT HOLDS
HIS APOLOGY FROM ADVISOR- IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY- BRAND HAS
BEEN A LEADER IN RESEARCH ON
WHOLE ORCHARD RECYCLING AND
ALMONDS AND HE'S ALSO ON. THE
SIDE AND EXPERT ON COMPOST
SPREADERS SO- YOU KNOW HIS
RESEARCH IS NOT ONLY HELPING TO
ON FIELD TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY
IN OUR REGION BUT WE'RE ALSO
ABLE TO TAP INTO HIS EXPERTISE.
TELL SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM IN AND
GET THE CONCEPTS BY. TO THEIR
FARMS- ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
LEVERAGING RESOURCE DURING AN
OPEN- WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK
IN THE UC DAVIS WESTERN'S EVER
AGRICULTURAL HUB AND SAFETY AND
THEN ALSO THE UCSF- COMMITTEE
CODE NINETEEN EVERY PROJECT.
THAT SPACE IN FRESNO- THREE CSS
MEDICAL PROGRAMS AND THEN ALSO
ARE. INTERESTED COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFIT PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS- TO HELP WITH THE
ROLL OUT OF BOXING TO SOCIALLY
JUST. VANISHED FARMERS. AS PART
OF THE OF THE STUDENT ACT YOUR-
BUT SO. ONE OF THE MAJOR
BARRIERS FOR SMALL SCALE IS A
DISADVANTAGE FARMERS TO ACCESS
THE VACCINE HAS BEEN THAT
VACCINATION SITES. USUALLY ASK
FOR DOCUMENTATION LIKE A PASTE
UP. TO SHOW THAT YOU ARE
INTERESTED IN AGRICULTURE. BUT
IT. SMALL SCALE FARMER THERE'S
NO STANDARD DOCUMENTATION LIKE
A CASE TIME TO PROVE THAT AND
EVEN IF YOU SHOWED A PERMIT OR
A LICENSE THE STAFF AT THAT
CLINIC MIGHT NOT REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO LOOK FOR SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING YES UP TO DEVELOP A
PROCESS THAT ALLOWS FARMERS
THAT WE KNOW HOW TO GET ON A
LIST AND THEN WE PROVIDE TO
THE- CODE NINETEEN EQUITY
PROJECT AND THEY CAN GET
VACCINATED WITH JUST A PHOTO
ID. IS THERE ALREADY ON THE
LIST SO WE HAD OUT HERE TWENTY
FARMERS OR THAT SO FAR I MEAN%
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW
WE TRY TO FILL IN THE GAPS IN
OUTREACH AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SO THAT- SMALL SCALE
AND SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS CAN GET THE RESOURCES
THAT OTHERWISE. MIGHT NOT MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO ACCESS- BUT
THERE'S DEFINITELY MORE WORK TO
BE DONE IN THAT AREA AND WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH- AGENCIES. AND-
MARKETING PARTNER. NOW THE
LARGEST. TO YOU KNOW TO
INCREASE EQUITY INCREASE ACCESS
TO RESOURCES HOW ARE WE CANNOT.
SO I'M GONNA. STOP HERE AND
TURN IT OVER TO YOU MICHAEL
YET. ALSO HAS- GONNA TALK MORE
ABOUT OUR WORK WITH SOCIAL
DISADVANTAGE FARMERS. THAT'S
GREAT IF I GET IN TROUBLE
QUICKLY TO FORMALLY INTRODUCE
MICHAEL REALLY APPRECIATE
INFORMATION RUTH AND MICHAEL IS
EIGHT MONTH AGRICULTURAL
ASSISTANT FOR THE UC
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION SMALL
FARM PROGRAM IN FRESNO COUNTY
HE'S SUPPORTED- THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF IMMIGRANTS
REFUGEES AND UNDERSERVED. SMALL
SCALE FARMERS FOR THE PAST
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS HE'S WORKED
VERY HARD TO BUILD TRUST
RELATIONSHIPS AND WITH THAT
WELCOME MICHAEL. AND IT'S ALL
YOURS. THANK YOU ROBERT THANK
YOU FOR- COMING DOWN TO FRESNO
AND VISIT US A SMALL FARM IN
THIS AREA. EIGHT TAKING TIME
DOWN HERE- THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE- I- TELL YOU LIVE ABOUT
MYSELF- WHAT I DO HERE- I AM
LONG I SPEAK MOM THAT ALSO
SPEAK LOUD SO IN FRESNO WE HAVE
A LARGE COMMUNITY OF OUR
FARMERS IN FRESNO- MAINLY THE
MAJORITY ARE SMALL BUT WE HAVE-
LAO. CAMBODIAN MEN COME IN
BLACK HOLE EACH OF THOSE- AND
THEY GROUP WE HAVE DIFFERENT
CULTURE DIFFERENT LANGUAGE WE
MAY LOOK THE SAME BUT WE ALL
SPEAK DIFFERENT LANGUAGE AND SO
I ONLY SPEAK MAGA AND ALLOW
ALSO LIKE- YOU KNOW OUR SERVICE
THIS WHOLE. OUR COMMUNITY- VERY
DIVERSE IN AND PEOPLE AND CRY
AND SO- WHAT I DO I PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT I ORGANIZED
AND COORDINATED ORGANIZED.
MEETING BRING THEM TOGETHER I
TRANSLATE FOR THEM- YOU KNOW
WITH ALL THE PROGRAMS COME AND
THAT- FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW-
LABOR OSHA SIX MAYA- A GOOD
LAND REGULATORY PROGRAMS AND
CAMPUSES SITE PASSES I STATE
THE ALL THAT AND THERE'S MORE-
IT REALLY TO FARM FARMING SO I
A PROVIDE. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IN THOSE AREAS ARE TRANSLATE
MATERIAL- ONE EGG. I WANT TO
GIVE YOU EXAMPLE LIKE. IF
THERE'S VERY REGULATORY-
COMPLIANCE THESE FARMERS NEED
TO UNDERSTAND- TO BE TO BE
COMPLIANCE AND SO WHAT EXAMPLE
ONE THE- IN THE PAST I DID. YOU
KNOW OUR FACES ISSUE WHERE
LABOR AND OSHA HAS YOU KNOW
THEY THEY'RE OUT THERE AND
THERE IS DRIVING VERY FAST YOU
KNOW IN THE MIDWEST PAST
SUMMER- HOT SUMMER. THE DRIVER
AFFAIRS FASTED FIELDS AND STOP
AND THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF
DOES THE AND ON A DAY WHEN I
CAME OUT GET SUED THREE
INSPECTOR ASKING THEY- YOU
KNOW- AND NON ENGLISH YOU KNOW
OUR SPEAKING FARMER SAY WELL
YOUR YOUR WATER WAS YOUR YOU
KNOW- PUT A POTTY AND ALL THAT
AND WHAT'S YOUR WATER AND THIS
OLD LADY NEW HE GOES ALL HE ME
WATER RIGHT. AND I SHE WENT
OVER AND GRAB A CUP OF WATER IN
AND THEN SPECTER ST NOW THAT'S
ON. THE WATER WE LOOKING FOR
NOW. HAVING ALL THE- REGULAR.
AGENCY YOU KNOW. IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE IN
COMPLIANCE. THERE HAS TO BE
TRAINING HAS TO BE. YOU KNOW
TRANSLATION IN THE END OF WAY
THAT THE- THESE DIFFERENT YOU
KNOW OUR ETHNIC GROUP I
UNDERSTAND. AND YOU CAN'T YOU
KNOW- JUST YOU CANNOT JUST- PUT
OUT A MASS LETTER SENT OUT TO
THE PUBLIC AND EXPECT THESE
COMEDIAN TO STAND YOUR YOUR
REGULATIONS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WHEN THESE- ISSUES
YOU KNOW ARE ARE RISING PASSING
ASKED HIM. HOW MANY MEETINGS
DID YOU YOU KNOW- PROVIDE FOR
THESE A GROUP OF PEOPLE ARE DIG
DEEPER PHARMA THEY SAID SO MANY
MEETING BUT WE ASK YOU KNOW HOW
MANY HOW MANY OF THEM A CHECK A
TEN YEAR TRAINING. THEY SAID IT
LOOKS LIKE THIS ONE LOOKS LOOKS
ASIAN YOU KNOW AND SOMETHING
LIKE THAT JUST GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE WE NEED TO HAVE SOMEONE
WHO. COULD COMMUNICATE AND
PROVIDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
YOU KNOW- I THINK THERE'S A YOU
KNOW OUR PROVIDE A VIEW ALSO
GROUPS THAT TALK ABOUT A WEEK I
MYSELF EXPECTS PERRANCE AND
THESE ARE WITH THAT YOU KNOW
ALL THESE REGULATORY AGENCY AND
SELL. JUST SO WE ON THE
COMMITTEE KNOWS THAT THERE'S A
NEED YOU KNOW THERE'S A-
LANGUAGE BARRIER AND- YES
SERVING THESE COMMUNITY SO.
HERE FRESNO LIKE I SAID- ALL
THEY STILL THE SAME THEM MOMENT.
ARE THERE MITCHELL. OF THEM
HAVE ALLOW WE HAVE BEEN ME AND
WE SERVE ALL THE GOOD AND WE
HAVE TO ASK MATTER FONG HERE TO
WHICH I WORK WITH. AND THE-
HISPANIC GROWERS NOW THAT
DENTAL YOU. AND SO YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT ALL THESE YOU KNOW- MY
GROUP TOGETHER. MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO NOT PROVIDE. YOU KNOW-
YOU KNOW AT TRAINING AND SO
THAT THEY IN COMPLIANCE SO THIS
IS JUST AN EXAMPLE WHAT I. YOU
KNOW- ARE DID AND- LIKE I SAID
I HOSTED RADIO- A PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE. YOU KNOW- AT. JUST
JUST TOPICS ABOUT AG RELATED TO
THE WHOLE SINCE RALLIED FROM
BAKERSFIELD TO OPT TO STOCKTON
I DO GET A CALL FROM
SACRAMENTO. AND NOW WE JUST IS
STARTING A PROGRAM SIMILAR TO
WHAT I HAD HERE AND SO I HAD
PHARMACOL THE FROM. FROM ALL
THE COUNTY- BECAUSE WHEN I
SPEAK LONG AND- THEY JUST WANT
TO GET HELP- SO JUST SO THAT-
COMMITTEE MELT THAT WE- DO NEED
SOMEONE THAT CAN COMMUNICATE
AND PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THESE
YOU KNOW OUR UNDER SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY FARMING COMMUNITY. SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU HAVING ME
ON YEAH I JUST PROVIDE WHAT I
I'VE WORK- WITH YOU KNOW ON
THESE THESE GROUP OF PEOPLE.
OUT ARE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
RELATED TO AGRICULTURE THAT I
ALSO DO THINK THAT. WE YOU
KNOW- INDUCTIVE IN DIFFERENT IN
WE DO HAVE LOW ALLOW TO DO.
VARIETY OF US CROPS IN THIS
AREA AND- YOU KNOW WHAT THE
COLD AND EVERYTHING KINDA YOU
KNOW- A SLOW DOWN WHAT THEY'RE
FROM VISIT EVERY DAY BUT I DO
APPRECIATE IF ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT YOU'RE WILLING
TO COME DOWN FRESNO. I WILL
GIVE YOU A- HANDS ON EXPERIENCE
TO YOU KNOW- TO THAT SMALL FARM
IN THIS AREA AND SUCKS I DON'T
THINK YOU FOR HAVING ME-
POCKETS THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH MICHAEL WILL
CERTAINLY- WILL TAKE UP ON THAT
OFFER I THINK YOU KNOW THE
EXPERIENCE I SHARED ON THE
SMALL FARM WAS INCREDIBLY
EDUCATIONAL AND CERTAINLY. MORE
MEMBERS THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
EXPERIENCE THAT BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU TALKING ABOUT
THE WORK YOU DO AND- AND HOW
THAT'S TRANSLATED- TO
SUPPORTING- ARE. ARE ARE SMALL
AND- ARE DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND SO CERTAINLY THE WORK YOU
DO IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND
SO WITH THAT I WANT TO OPEN IT
UP TO- THE COMMITTEE- WHO FOR
ANY QUESTIONS ARE. DISPERSED
TOM. I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
COUPLE MEMBERS REMOTELY-
VIRTUALLY I KNOW. CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I
GUARD. CURRY WAS SET TO- LEAVE
IT- TEN THIRTY I'M NOT SURE
SHE'S STILL WITH US. YEAH I AM
DID YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. NO
I JUST WANNA MAKE A COMMENT- I
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
SPEAKERS TODAY THEY'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB I JUST CAUSING MORE-
I GET MORE EXCITED. MORE FULL
ABOUT THE THINGS WE CAN HELP DO
I'M AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT I
AM REALLY CONCERNED. OR NOT
CONCERNED I'M LOOKING AT LONG
TERM LAND LEASES AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH LAND TRUSTS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT BECAUSE
THERE ARE FARMERS. THAT ARE NO
LONGER- WANTED TO FARM
THOUSANDS OF ACRES BUT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO MAYBE FIGURE OUT
IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT A TAX
CREDIT OR SOMETHING FOR SOME OF
OUR FARMERS SO WE CAN GET LONG
TERM LEASES. ARE OUT THERE FOR
OF ROBERT DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
SO I'M TRYING TO THINK OUTSIDE
THE BOX EVEN HAS ANY IDEAS WE'D
REALLY APPRECIATE IT I'VE
REACHED OUT TO A COUPLE PEOPLE
THERE LOOKING ACROSS THE NATION
TO SEE IF THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE- BUT I
THINK WE- YEAH- YES CERTAINTY
OF OUR FARMERS. ISN'T IS
TERAMO- YOU CAN'T VERY WELL AND
SAY THAT YOU CAN HAVE A FEW
CYLINDRICAL FOR YEARS YOU PUT
YOUR INVESTMENTS IN THERE YOU
CAN'T GO AFTER- AFTER YOU CAN'T
ACCESS IN THE CAPITAL. SO
THERE'S STILL WORK TO DO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU- PLEASE REACH OUT TO- TO
THIS COMMITTEE OR MYSELF AND
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO GING
FORWARD SO AGAIN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND AGAIN I WANT TO THINK
YEAH BECAUSE IF WE HAVEN'T HAD
A- SOMEONE TO GUIDE US ALONG
AND IMPLEMENT THE BILL IT
PROBABLY BE SITTING STILL ON
THE SHELF BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
SWAMPED BUT THIS IS BEEN A
REALLY. GOOD INVESTMENT IS
HAVING- SOMEONE THEY CAN PUT
THE WHOLE PROGRAM TOGETHER SO
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE A
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH-
RUTH AND MICHAEL AND- CDFA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND THANKS FOR BEING
WITH US THIS MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ANNA QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER SO
OFTEN. SO WE OF THE RECOMMENDED.
IN THE- TWO FOR- SPECIFICALLY
TO LEGISLATURE'S. THAT TO
HIGHLIGHTED. OF CALIFORNIA
FARMERS AND RANCHERS AND OUT
REACH MEDIAPOST HOWEVER. STILL
80% OF- CALIFORNIA FARMERS ARE
WHITE. WHAT MEASURES ARE CDFA
TAKING TO IMPLEMENT A PIPELINE
SPECIFICALLY FOR INDIVIDUALS IN
URBAN AREAS LIKE MINE- SO JUST
SOUTH LA TO BECOME FARMERS AND
WHAT MEASURES ARE IMPLEMENTED
TO ENSURE THEIR SUCCESS WHICH
IS PROBABLY EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHATEVER WE'RE DOING- THAT
IS IMPLEMENTED AND HAS
SUCCESSFUL. AND THAT WE DO ON
CURRENT ONGOING ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN IMPROVE THAT SYSTEM. NOT
SURE IF- SOME ON THE PANEL WANT
TO TAKE THAT QUESTION. I'D BE
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO THAT THANK
YOU THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION. I
THINK THAT URBAN FARMERS AS WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT WITH BOTH THE
U. S. THE ADVENTURES AND THEN
ALSO WITHIN CITY UPDATE
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE AN URBAN AG FOCUS
AND- SOME SOME NEW- I'D
MENTIONED DURING MY REPORT R.
DURING MY- PRESENTATION ABOUT.
FORMING AND- ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AND- WE HAVE MADE A CONSCIOUS
EFFORT TO INTENTIONAL EFFORT TO
INCLUDE- MEMBERS URBAN AG-
MEMBERS ON THAT COMMITTEE AND-
I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM DAM ABOUT HOW WE
CAN START TO CREATE. THOSE
PROGRAMS AND OPPORTUNITIES- I
THINK A LOT CAN DO IN THAT IN
THIS AREA AND I THINK THAT-
THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT WILL
COME WITH IN THIS YEAR FROM
ACTUALLY LISTENING AND LETTING
THOSE URBAN FARMERS GUIDE-
THOSE PRIORITIES AND- REALLY
TRY TO CREATE SOME. PROGRAMS
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK FOR
THEM. AND THEN IT WIL START TO
CREATE THAT TO WORK FOR THEM.
WHAT I. THERE ARE. GOING TO
TAKE. SHE KNOW I WOULD SAY ONE
PROGRAM THAT DOES THAT DOES
HAVE- AND- POTENTIAL INFLUENCE
AND IMPORTANCE WITH URBAN AG IS
OUR FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM AND
THIS IS A NEW GRANT PROGRAM
THAT WAS JUST- ACTUALLY THE R.
F. P. WAS JUST RECENTLY
RELEASED- AND SO THERE IS THAT
PROGRAM BUT- THERE ARE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES I THINK THAT NEED
TO BE REALIZED WITH REGARDS TO
URBAN FARMERS. GOOD BECAUSE
THERE THERE ARE SWATHS OF LAND.
WHERE IN SOUTH LA WHERE WE HAVE
A- OPTION ABANDONED INDUSTRY
AND WAREHOUSES- ARE JUST VACANT
LOTS EVERYWHERE ALL OVER SOUTH
LA. THAT WOULD BE AMENABLE TO
SOME KIND OF URBAN FARMING
ENDED BUT WE'VE NEVER REALLY
DEVELOPED AND- A ROBUST
PLANNED- TO ADDRESS IT- AND YOU
KNOW SOMEONE. THAT BELIEVES
THAT. ONE DAY ONCE. CANNABIS
IS- LEGALIZED FEDERALLY- WE
DON'T NEED AS MUCH LAND TO MAKE
A GOOD PROFIT AND THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY START TO
EMBRACE IT AND MAYBE EVEN TAKE
PARTS OF THEIR LAND TO HELP
WITH THE BOTTOM LINE- TWO BROKE
CANNABIS THAT MIGHT BE AN
EXCELLENT START IN ENDS IN
SOUTH LA AND OTHER PLACES AND
SO THAT WE CAN BUILD AN ECONOMY
THAT IS IN INDUSTRY AND SO-
RIGHT NOW THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
IS BECOMING PART OF THE LOS
ANGELES CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
OTHER CHAMBERS SO THEY'RE-
THEY'RE BECOMING PART OF THE
MAINSTREAM AND SO I THINK AS
NEW PRODUCTS COME UP. NOT JUST
THE TRADITIONAL PRODUCTS THAT
WE THINK ABOUT THE NEW PRODUCTS
COME UP- AGRICULTURE SHOULD
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT AND THEN
INCORPORATE- LANCE THERE ARE
NOT TRADITIONALLY IN YOUR WHAT
YOU WOULD THINK YOU SHOULD DO
THAT STINKS THERE ARE KIND OF
OUT OF THE BOX SO- I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION WITH
THE AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE- WOULD HATE FOR YOU TO
MISS OUT ON A ON A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE YOUR-
YOUR NOW YOUR MEMBERSHIP. BUT
YOUR BOTTOM LINE YOUR PRODUCT
LINE. ANY OTHER. FROM I'M SORRY.
I WOULD JUST NOTE TO THAT- THAT
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION ALSO HAS
A VERY- STRONG SUPPORT IN THE
URBAN AND COMMUNITY FOR-
OUTREACH AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE I'M AND YOU ALSO
HERE IN THE FARMER PANEL FROM-
DORIA ROBINSON WHO IS ALSO
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN URBAN
AGRICULTURE AND IT- VERY WELL
RESPECTED AND WILL PROBABLY
HAVE A LOT O SAY ABOUT THIS SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING HER.
COMMENTS AS WELL. REALLY
APPRECIATE- THAT FEEDBACK ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE QUESTIONS. STRUCTURE AT
THIS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
MIKE ON THERE WE GO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- YOU KNOW I REALLY
WANT TO GO BACK TO- TO MICHAEL
YANG I APPRECIATE HIS COMMENTS-
YOU KNOW I THINK A LOT OF WHAT
HE HAD TO SAY IN REGARDS TO THE
LANGUAGE BARRIER. THAT'S OUT
THERE I KNOW IN MY COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE ALLOW LONG IN FILIPINO-
IN SEVERAL OTHER DIALECTS-
THERE IN THERE I THINK TOO
OFTEN FROM A STATE BUREAUCRATIC
LEVEL- BUT WE DO SEND OUT MASS
LETTERS- IN THERE ARE. IT IS
MULTI LINGUAL AS THEY OUGHT TO
BE- SO I THINK THERE'S
DEFINITELY ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT
WITH THAT AND I'D REALLY LIKE
TO SEE THAT- GOING BACK TO- MY-
COLLEAGUE MISTER JONES SAWYER
IS- COMMENTS- I'D- LIKE TO ASK
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE URBAN AG
PROGRAM THAT WE USED TO HAVE. I
KNOW- THE SCHOOL PROGRAM THE
FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM WAS
MENTIONED BUT WE DID HAVE A
URBAN AG PROGRAM I REMEMBER
WHEN I WAS FIRST UP HERE SEVEN
YEARS AGO AS A FRESHMAN- IN
THIS COMMITTEE. LEARNING ABOUT
THAT AND HOW WE ARE DOING WORK
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND OTHER
AREAS TO TAKE SOME OF THESE
PLOTS OF LAND IN AND TURN THEM
INTO COMMUNITY GARDENS WHAT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THAT WHAT
HAS HAPPENED WITH THAT AND HOW
COME WE'RE NOT UTILIZING- THOSE
TOOLS TO- BREACH SOME OF THESE
GAPS. DONALD ONCE. PARK WHERE
HE. THAT IS SEE IF THEY PROGRAM.
IT'S THAT THAT I DO I REMEMBER
THAT BACK FROM FRESHMAN YEAR
READ YOU BELONG HERE LONGER
THAN ME OF IT- NOW WE THERE
THERE'S BEEN A IT MAY HAVE
THAT. I'M HERE THANK YOU THE
ALL AT THE AGENCY MANY ALSO
KNOW THIS STUFF. MAYBE WE NEED
TO. YEAH MAY MAYBE WE NEED TO
RE LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE- I MEAN
I REMEMBER TALKING ABOUT THAT I
KNOW ON ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL OR
SOME PROGRAMS LIKE THAT AS
WELL- WE SHOULD DEFINITELY BE
PARTNERING- TO DO THESE THINGS
AND THEN- AND- ANOTHER QUESTION
BACK TO THE AGENCY- IN FRANKLY
WE- WE HEAR THIS WITH ALL THE
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. ABOUT
THE- THE FACT THAT THERE'S
OUTREACH AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- BUT WHAT DOES THAT
ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW IT FOR ME IS A IS A COMBAT
VETERAN EVER WHEN I GOT HOME
FROM THE WAR THERE LIKE. APRIL
HERE'S A BOOKLET OF YOUR
BENEFITS GOOD LUCK WITH THE
SIZING FONG. SO I HOPE WE'RE
DOING BETTER THAN THAT- AS FAR
AS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GOES
BECAUSE I THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
I LEARNED. ON ON MY WAY UP
THROUGH THROUGH COLLEGE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE LEARNING ABOUT
HOW GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS WORK
GET TOGETHERS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IF YOU KNOW WHERE TO
FIND IT. SO WHAT ARE WE DOING.
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO HELP. OUR
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES LIKE
MICHAEL GANGS IN AND OTHER
FOLKS HELP THEM GET ACCESS TO
THAT INFORMATION BECAUSE IT'S
GREAT IF WE HAVE A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. BUT NOBODY
KNOWS HOW TO GET A HOLD OF IT
OR WHERE TO FIND IT IT'S
USELESS. AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE HAVE
NOT NOT JUST WITH THE AG SECTOR
BUT OUR- BUREAUCRACIES IN THE
STATE ACROSS THE BOARD. NOBODY
NOBODY KNOWS WHERE TO GO TO
ACCESS THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
SO WHAT'S BEING DONE TO ENSURE
THAT THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IS ACCESSIBLE. IS BEING ROUTED
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT SOMETHING I
SAID. IN IN REYES USED TO MAKE
FUN OF ME FOR THIS BECAUSE
BECAUSE I USED TO BE LIVE WHERE
WHERE IS AN APP FOR THAT. YOU
KNOW WE'RE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WITH THE
TAKEOVER OF THE WORLD. HOW CAN
THESE GUYS DON'T HAVE AN APP
THAT THEY CAN DOWNLOAD. THE
THAT GIVES ON THE TECHNICAL
SYSTEMS RIGHT THERE ON THEIR
PHONE. IN AND I KNOW PART OF
THE ANSWER TO THAT IS BECAUSE
OUR COMPUTER SYSTEMS ARE OVER
THIRTY YEARS OLD BUT- THAT'S-
I'M I'M WORKING ON A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL FIX THAT ONE BUT
LET WHAT IT WAS THE AGENCY
DOING. THE AGENCY IS DOING.
SARM A LITTLE SPICY MORNING IF.
WHO'S BEST ON THE PANEL TO-
RESPOND TO SOME OF OUR MATHIS
IS QUESTION I'M SORRY AB I WAS
ON MUTE APOLOGIZE OF THIS IS
THE- WITH CDFA- AND THIS WAS
WHAT I REFERRED TO WITHIN THE
PRESENTATION ABOUT ON THE
RELIANCE ON- LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS-
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE NOT ONLY
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE BUT ALL
THE IMPLEMENTATION ASSISTANT
THIS IS SOMETHING- AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN WAS PASSED
ALSO TO HELP INSURE THAT IDIOT
BATES CLIMATE SMART ACT
PROGRAMS WERE ACTUALLY. WE WERE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BUT NOT ONLY APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE BUT IMPLEMENTATION
ASSISTANT THAT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
QUITE SUCCESSFUL MENTIONED THAT
AS WELL AS THE FOOD SAFETY-
THERE IS THE CONTINUAL NEED TO
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE-
STAFF CAPACITY TO BE A NEW.
LOCAL YOU KNOW ALL OVER THE
STATE WE RELY ON PARTNERS AND
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT BOTH
PARTNERS ARE ADEQUATELY FUNDED
AND ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN IN
LANGUAGES- OF THE ARAB
COMMUNITY AND THEN. ALSO- TECH
ASSISTANCE THAT IS. FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND THEN WHAT WITH
REGARDS TO A AND URBAN AG
PROGRAM THERE WAS URBAN AG
INCENTIVE ZONING LAWS. THAT
REPRESENTATIVE TEAM HELP TO
PASS THAT I WASN'T AWARE OF
BECAUSE I JUST STARTED IT CDFA
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- BUT- IF YOU
LIKE TO HAVE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT IT WAS SOMETHING
THAT THE COUNTIES IMPLEMENT NOT
CDFA- COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS WILL BE A GOOD
RESOURCE TO REFER TO FOR MORE
INFORMATION. IF YOU HAVE
FURTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE RESPONSE
WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT ELEVEN
THIRTY SO I'M GONNA HAVE TO
PUSH THIS DISCUSSION TO OUR
NEXT PANEL BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE TIME YOU
GUYS HAVE- MADE FOR- THIS
HEARING- AND APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE AROUND THE URBAN AG
INCENTIVES PROGRAM IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT SAM CISCO IN
L. A. ARE THE ONLY CITIES- OR
TWO OF THE LARGEST CITIES IN
OUR STATE THAT HAVE ADOPTED-
AND OPTED INTO THE PROGRAM SO.
BUT BUT WITH THAT WE GET SOME
IF- GET- SOME FOLLOW UP
INFORMATION AROUND THAT BUT
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH IN OUR
OUR SECOND PANEL. IS HERE TO
FOCUS ON FARMER. ON ON. WHICH
WHICH IS GONNA FOCUS ON FARM X.
ON FOOT. ON FARMER EQUITY
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES- OUR
FIRST PANELIST IS. PART THREE
CELL RODRIGUEZ WHO IS A
STRAWBERRY GROWER AND TOGETHER
WITH OUR HOUSE WITH HER HUSBAND
ROSARIO. OWNS RODRIGUEZ FARMS
IN CASTROVILLE CALIFORNIA. SHE
STARTED IN THE FIELD AS A FARM
WORKER. BEFORE TRANSITIONING TO
A STRAWBERRY GROWER. SHE ALSO
TRANSITION FROM BEING A
TRADITIONAL GROW TO AN ORGANIC
GROWER. AND CURRENTLY FARMS-
NINETY ACRES SO WELCOME TO THIS
HEARING MISTRUST REGUS AND- AND
IF YOU ARE READY TO GO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT WAS FOR
HAVING ME AND THANK YOU ALL- I
AM VERY EXCITED TO- LISTEN TO
ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE GOING
ON WITH THEM ASSISTANCE FOR
FARMERS BECAUSE BACK WHEN. WE
STARTED YOU KNOW TODAY THIS
YEAR WE CELEBRATE THIRTY YEARS
AND LIKE YOU MENTIONED-
TOGETHER WITH MY HUSBAND WE
STARTED- FARMING AND THIS IS
AFTER- YOU KNOW WORKING IN THE
FIELDS OURSELVES AS SPEAKERS I
WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
WATSONVILLE CALIFORNIA. AND
STARTED WORKING AT THE FARM
SINCE I CAN REMEMBER BECAUSE WE
LIVED AT THE FARM SO SINCE
EARLY AGE I REMEMBER- YOU KNOW
COMING OUT AND HELPING WITH
WHATEVER I COULD UNTIL I BECAME
AN ADULT. AND YOU KNOW WITH
THAT EXPERIENCE I EIGHTY WE
VENTURED OUT INTO THE FARMING
WORLD TOGETHER WITH MY HUSBAND
HIS FAMILY ALSO- WORK THERE.
AND IT HAS BEEN A LONG AND-
JUST INCREDIBLE JOURNEY BECAUSE
WHEN WE STARTED AND- WE FELT
THAT WE KNEW ENOUGH ABOUT
FARMING YOU KNOW TO START OUR
OWN BUSINESS BUT QUICKLY
LEARNED THAT THERE WAS- A LOT
OF IT THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
IN MAINLY- A LOT OF THINGS ARE
BEING TALKED ABOUT LIKE-
APPLYING- FOR DIFFERENT PERMITS
AND JUST FOLLOWING REGULATIONS
AND YOU KNOW WHEN WE WERE. VERY
PICKERS WE DON'T HAVE TO DO ANY
OF THAT AND SO QUICKLY WE WERE
FACED WITH A LOT OF CHALLENGES
AND THE FIRST ONE WAS YOU KNOW
WHEN LOOKING FOR LAND YOU KNOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS YOU KNOW FOR A
SMALL FARMER STARTING UP TO THE
ACCORDING TO LAND. AND MOST-
PEOPLE WHO WERE LEASING LAND
ONE AND- REFERENCES WE DID A
CREDIT CHECK AND WE HAD NOTHING
SO IT TOOK US YOU KNOW MONTHS
UNTIL WE WERE ABLE TO. FIND
SOMEONE THAT WOULD JUST TAKE
OUR WORD AND TRUST US YOU KNOW
TO YOU KNOW PAY THEM THE RENT
SO WE STARTED WITH THREE ACRES.
AND THEN SHORTLY AFTER- THE
OTHER CHALLENGE WAS EQUIPMENT-%
MOST. OF US NEED A LOT OF YOU
KNOW DE FOR TOOLS LIKE. AND
AGAIN YOU KNOW THIS CHANNEL.
WERE IF YOU DON'T HAVE THEM-
WHEN YOU GO TO THESE PLACES
THAT RENT EQUIPMENT TO THIS DAY
THEY HAVE LONG APPLICATIONS.
AND HALF OF IT YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO- COMPLETE BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE REFERENCES AGAIN
YOU KNOW CREDIT. SO FOR MANY
YEARS- WHAT WE HAD TO DO WAS
JUST BE RESOURCEFUL AND GO OUT
TO OTHER FARMERS AND WE KNOW
OUR COMMUNITY AND ASKED TO
BORROW OR RENT FROM THEM AND
THAT'S HOW WE MADE IT WORK.
UNTIL WE WERE SLOWLY- YOU KNOW
SAVING MONEY AND ACQUIRED OUR
OWN EQUIPMENT. SO I AND YOU
KNOW WHEN I THINK BACK- A LOT
OF WHAT I'VE LISTENED TO JUST
YOU KNOW. IS A LOT OF WHAT WE
WENT THROUGH WHERE. MY LOT OF
THESE PLACES AND RESOURCES WE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT AND- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A LOT MORE NOW AND
THERE IS YOU KNOW MORE WORK
AHEAD IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
WHAT. NEEDS TO BE DONE TO THE
HOUSE MORE OF THESE AGENCIES OR
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR FARMERS-
AND ALONG THE WAY I WANT TO
THANK YOU KNOW I KNOW OR-
COUNTY AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONER. THAT WAS A GREAT
START BECAUSE OUR PEOPLE WE
BECOME FAMILIAR WITH AND TRUST
AND THAT'S A GOOD YOU KNOW.
AGENCY I THINK THAT FIRST
FARMERS WHEN YOU'RE STARTING
OUT YOU KNOW IT'S SOMEONE YOU
BECOME TO KNOWING YOU TRUST AND
YOU KNOW THE STRAWBERRY
COMMISSION AND THEN WHEN WE
WERE FACED WITH THE CHALLENGE
OF- TRANSITIONING TO ORGANIC.
BECAUSE OUR CUSTOMERS NO LONGER
WANT IT- CONVENTIONAL BERRIES-
THAT WAS ANOTHER CHALLENGE
BECAUSE EVERYTHING WAS JUST
LIKE STARTING OVER BECAUSE IT
WAS LEARNING THE NEW
FERTILIZERS OR WHAT WAS GOING
TO WORK WITH THEM. YOU KNOW
FARMING ORGANIC BALANCE HE COS
WAS- THEY WERE VERY GOOD AND
HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES FOR US.
SO- OVERALL AND I'M- LIKE I SAY
YOU KNOW IT'S VERY CHALLENGING
WHEN YOU START. FROM THE BOTTOM
FROM ZERO AND THE MAIN
CHALLENGES ARE YOU KNOW THE
LAND HAVE READING YOU KNOW
EQUIPMENT AND THEN ASSISTANCE
WITH- GETTING THE PERMITS ARE
FOLLOWING REGULATIONS AND FOR
ME YOU KNOW. SPEAKING ENGLISH
IT WAS DIFFICULT BECAUSE A LOT
OF THE LANGUAGE AND THESE
APPLICATIONS ARE NOT COMMON
ENGLISH WORDS THAT I WAS
FAMILIAR WITH SO I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE HOW MUCH HARDER IT IS
FOR SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T SPEAK
ENGLISH- YES SO. NOW THIS YEAR
LIKE I SAY WE CELEBRATE THIRTY
YEARS AND AFTER MANY CHALLENGES
I THINK WE WERE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE WE NEVER
GAVE UP. AND WE WERE
RESOURCEFUL AND I THINK MANY OF
US MALL LOCAL FARMERS YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT- HELPS ME SUCCESS
WELL WE JUST BECOME
RESOURCEFUL. AND WORK WITH EACH
OTHER. WON'T MISS RODRIGUEZ WE
APPRECIATE- YOUR TESTIMONY AND
EXAMPLES YOU SHARED IF YOU'LL
PLEASE HOLD ON THE LINE I'M
SURE WE'LL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
AT THE END OF THE PANEL. BUT
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US-
THE NEXT PANELIST- IS DORIA
ROBINSON SHE'S EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF URBAN HEALTH A
COLLECTION OF SCHOOLS AND- SOME
COMMUNITY GARDENS AND SMALL
URBAN FARMS IN RICHMOND- THERE
USED TO TEACH AN EMPLOYEE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO GROW. TO
DISTRIBUTE COOK AND EAT LOCAL
PRODUCE NOTABLY SHE IS A
CERTIFIED PERMACULTURE DESIGNER
CERTIFIED BABY FRIENDLY GARDEN.
A CERTIFIED NUTRITION EDUCATOR.
AND WHAT MUST BE A VERY LIMITED
TIME AND HERB AND HER LIFE
SHE'S ALSO A CERTIFIED YOGA
INSTRUCTOR. A WELCOME MISS
ROBINSON GROUP WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
THANK YOU I'M NOT SURE IF THE
IF MY VIDEO IS WORKING IS IT IS
IT ALL GOOD YEAH I'M GOOD. ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION- HERE. AND I WANT TO
SEE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT URBAN
TOLD BECAUSE I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW I REALLY WANT TO GIVE A
GOOD IS. UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN TERMS OF URBAN
AGRICULTURE- SO URBAN TOTH IS A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
HERE IN RICHMOND CALIFORNIA IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO EAST BAY WERE
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD- LIKE I SAID
OUR MISSION IS TO HIRE AND
TRAIN LOCAL RESIDENTS TO
CULTIVATE AGRICULTURE FEED OUR
COMMUNITY RESTORE ELATION SAYS
WITH LAND. AND BUILD A MORE
SUSTAINABLE FOOD SYSTEM WITHIN
A JUST AND HEALTHIER COMMUNITY
I SAY THAT BECAUSE IN RICHMOND
LAST WEEK EIGHTY TWO PEOPLE
DIED OF CARBON JUSTIN RICHMOND
WHICH MEANS THE TOWN OF A
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE. THAT THE WEEK BEFORE IT
WAS SEVENTY FOUR. WE HAVE
HIGHER INSTANCES OF THINGS LIKE
KOBE IT BECAUSE WE HAVE HIGHER
INSTANCES OF THINGS LIKE HEART
DISEASE DIABETES OBESITY- ALL
OF THESE PREVENTABLE DISEASES-
BUT WE ALSO HAVE REALLY POOR
ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOODS WE HAVE
TONS OF CONVENIENCE STORES FAST
FOOD. JOINTS AND ONE FULL
SERVICE GROCERY STORE. OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN IS ENDING FOOD
DESERT INCLUDE SWAMPS- HELPING
RESIDENTS RECONNECT WITH THEIR
OWN HEALTH IT SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY DECREASE OUR
VULNERABILITY TO STARKEY MUNITY
LIKE COBIT NINETEEN. CURRENTLY
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE IS WE
EMPLOY FORTY FOUR RICHMOND SAN
PABLO RESIDENTS MOSTLY YOUTH OF
COLOR FROM THIS COMMUNITY AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT- TO WORK ON OUR SIX
DIFFERENT SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
GARDENS AND URBAN FARMS HERE IN
RICHMOND WE HAVE TO CSA'S. ONE
CSA IS A FOOD IT'S A FOOD BOX
PROGRAM- SERVICE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FAMILIES- DELIVERING.
FOOD THAT WE GROW FOOD THAT WE
GET FROM SMALL BY PARK LOCAL
FARMERS- IT SAYS SUBSIDIZE THAT
MEMBER SUBSIDIZED CSA SO SOME
PEOPLE CHOOSE TO PAY MORE SO WE
CAN MAKE VERY LOW INCOME BOXES
AVAILABLE SAME BOX DIFFERENT
PRICE. AND THEN AS OF CODE WHEN
KOBE BEGAN WE STARTED A SECOND
CSA PER TWO HUNDRED FAMILIES
THIS IS EVERY WEEK- COMPLETELY
FREE FOR PEOPLE WHO WERE
EXTREMELY. IMPACTED BY COPA
CONVEYED. WHAT REALIZED IN THE
COURSE OF DOING NOW FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BOXES A WEEK
DELIVERED TO PEOPLE'S HOMES IS
THAT WE HAD EXTREME FOOD ACCESS
ISSUES ONE GOING BEFORE KOBE
KOBE JUST MADE IT REALLY
APPARENT- WE ALSO HAVE SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS YOU'VE BEEN
TEACHING IN URBAN AGRICULTURE
IN AMERICAN FOOD SYSTEMS CLASS
AT RICHMOND HIGH SCHOOL AS A
PART OF AN ELECTIVE COURSE FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS WE JUST ACTUALLY
GOT THAT- UPGRADED SO NOW IT'S-
COLLEGE SCIENCE- CREDIT COURSE.
WELL AND WE HAVE A SUMMER YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM FOR
FORTY YOUTH EVERY SUMMER THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS GETTING LOTS OF YOUTH
IRVINE YOUTH EXCITED ABOUT
FARMING MANY OF THOSE YOU THAT
THEY USE THAT BECOME- OUR FARM
MANAGERS ARE FARM COORDINATORS-
THAT ARE RUNNING THESE PROGRAMS
I'M TALKING ABOUT- THE USDA.
SUPPORTED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE FREE CSA PROGRAM- THROUGH
THEIR FARMERS TO FAMILIES
PROGRAM. DURING THE FIRST FEW
MONTHS OF THAT PROGRAM AND THEN
GROWING THE TABLE TOOK OVER TO
HELP FUND IT. WE ALSO HAVE A
PROGRAM. WITH THE LOCAL-
MEDICAL CLINIC AND LYFT ONE
MEDICAL CENTER TO DO A VEGGIE
ARE EX PROGRAM WHICH IS FREE
CSA BOXES GOING TO. THEIR
PATIENTS WHO ARE ACTUALLY
STRUGGLING WITH CHRONIC DISEASE
WHO WANT TO MAKE CHANGES IN
THEIR IN THEIR HEALTH- FREEZE-
CSA BOXES- AS A PART OF A
PRESCRIPTION FROM THEIR DOCTOR.
TO HELP THEM IMPROVE THEIR
HEALTH AND DECREASE THE IMPACTS
OF THE KIND OF KIND OF DISEASE
AND SOME AND SOME IN SOME CASES
REVERSE IT. I WANT TO ALSO SAY
THAT ALL OF OUR PROJECTS ARE ON
PUBLIC LANDS. ON SCHOOL
DISTRICT LAND ITS CITY LANDS
IT'S COUNTY LANDS WE HAVE A
VERY TENUOUS TENDENCY A
TENDENCY- IN OUR ON OUR GARDENS
FOR A FOR THESE SIXTEEN YEARS
WE NEVER KNOW. FOR MOST OF
THEIR LOCATIONS IT WILL BE
THERE THE NEXT YEAR ALTHOUGH WE
BUILT SUCH A STRONG REPUTATION
WITHIN THIS COMMUNITY BECAUSE
WE ARE ACTUALLY ALL FROM THIS
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
STAY IN PLACE BUT IF IT IS A
QUESTION AND IT'S BEEN HARD TO
ACTUALLY BUILD THE KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HELPS GET
COULD HELP US SCALE OUR IMPACT.
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE THERE ABOUT PEOPLE WE
SAY WE CAN ONLY DO TEMPORARY
THINGS- MOST RECENTLY WE
PARTNER WITH SUPERVISOR JOHN
GIOIA HAD TO DEVELOP THE NORTH
RICHMOND FARM WHICH IS A THREE
ACRE FARM IN NORTH RICHMOND. ON
COUNTY LAND IT WAS A LOT OF
CASH OF A VACANT LOT FOR FORTY
YEARS AND SUPERVISOR GIOIA
FOUNDED AND WE WORK TOGETHER TO
CREATE. WHAT IS NOW THE
BEGINNING OF THE NORTH RICHMOND
FARM- IT CURRENTLY HAS A ACRE
IN PRODUCTION AFTER A LONG
PROCESS TO GET TO THIS POINT.
I'LL SAY A LITTLE FEW WORDS
ABOUT THAT LATER- AND- NINETY
THREE TREAT WORKERS ORCHARD
CRYING APRICOTS PEARS
PERSIMMONS APPLES THE REST IS
IN ROW CROPS. SO I WANTED TO
SEE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THE
STATE I FEEL HAS BEEN DOING
REALLY RIGHT- WHAT KIND OF
SUPPORT HAS REALLY WORKED FOR
US. AND PEOPLE OF SAID UC
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION I WANT TO
SAY THAT AGAIN- WE GET SO MUCH
REALLY HIGH QUALITY SUPPORT
FROM THE UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION HERE ROB BENNINGTON
AND EVERYONE THERE WE GOT
SUPPORT WITH HIS MAN- MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE COMPLIANT AND
HOW THAT THE SAFETY PLAN IN
PLACE. AND THEY HELPED US
THROUGH THAT PROCESS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW. WE'RE ACTUALLY FROM
THIS COMMUNITY FROM VERY FEW OF
US HAVE HAVE- YOU KNOW DEGREES
AND ANYTHING LIKE THAT IN AND
IT'S A PRETTY ARDUOUS PROCESS
TO- BE FOODS FOOD SAFETY
CERTIFIED- WE HAVE- WE'VE
GOTTEN ADDED VALUE PRODUCT
CREATION SUPPORT IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE UNDERSTAND HOW DID YOU
MAKE ADDED VALUE PRODUCTS
LEGALLY. FROM THE UC
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION WE'VE
GOTTEN TRAINING FUND I PM IN
DEALING WITH PESTS IN ORGANIC
SYSTEMS IN SUPPORT AND IF COSTA
TRAINING AT OUR FARM ON SALE
HELP FOR OTHER OF URBAN
FARMERS. THEY'VE JUST BEEN AN
INVALUABLE RESOURCE ALSO. THE
WAY THAT CDFA HAS IT AIMS TO
CSA I. HAS BEEN. HELPFUL IT
REALLY SIMPLE. MAINTAIN A VALID
CS LIES. AND TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT FOOD HOPE
THAT CONNECTOR FOR OUR FAMILIES
IN RICHMOND'S SOON WHOLE
HEALTHY FOOD- AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO REALLY POINT THAT OUT
AND SAY THAT THOSE THINGS ARE
GOING. REALLY RIGHT- AND THEN
JUST ALSO WANT TO SAVE THAT
COMMUNITY. ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THE ALLIANCE- COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS-
THE CENTER FOR LAND BASED
LEARNING AND- URBAN EDGE FARM
IN BRENTWOOD. SPIRAL GARDENS
BRING SECURITY PROJECT AN OXEN
ARSENIC QUALITY CENTER ALL
PLACES THAT. HAVE REALLY HELPED
US GROW THROUGH THEIR WORKSHOPS
THROUGH JUST PEER TO PEER
TRAINING WITH URBAN EDGE FARM
THEY HELPED US PUT TOGETHER OUR
NURSERY. AND ARE GREENHOUSE
SYSTEMS KIND OF SHARED WHAT
THEY WERE DOING ON THEIR FARM
WITH OUR YOUNG FARMERS I WILL
EXCHANGE. GOING ON THERE. AND
IT'S A HELPFUL I WANTED TO
POINT THAT OUT THAT I HOPE THE
STATE CAN REALLY SUPPORT THOSE.
GROUPS THAT ARE WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY THAT ARE REACHING OUT
TO OTHER GROUPS TO HELP SUPPORT
THEIR GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT.
AND FINALLY I WANTED TO HIT ON
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THE LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE MENTIONED THEM
OWNERSHIP THAT CONTINUES TO BE
A CHALLENGE TO S. FOR US- UNTIL
DAYS LIKE I SAID COMPLETELY RUN
BY RICHMOND SAN PABLO
RESIDENTS. WE DON'T HAVE MONEY
WE DON'T HAVE CREDIT. WE DON'T
HAVE ASSETS. WE DON'T HAVE A
PATHWAY TO REALLY OWNING-
ANYTHING EXCEPT FOR THROUGH THE
WINTER PIERRE GRANT PROGRAMS.
AND- AND SO YOU KNOW WHEN WE
CAME ON THE NORTH RICHMOND FARM
PROJECTS. IT WAS LIKE SUCH A
BLESSING AND- AND AS WE'RE
DEVELOPING REALIZING THAT WE IN
ORDER TO DEVELOP THE PERMANENT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED WE
REALLY NEED TO OWN THE LAND
THAT'S HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
ACCESS TO THE FUNDS WE NEED TO
DEVELOP AN INFRASTRUCTURE- AND
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THAT WITH CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
WHO REALLY SUPPORTS OUR
PROJECT. IS REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT IT EXCEPT FOR THE NEW
SURPLUS LAND ACT. IT IS
ACTUALLY BLOCKING THE SALE OF
THE PROPERTY TO US- BECAUSE IT
HAS TO FIRST BE OFFERED TO LOW
INCOME HOUSING. AND YOU KNOW
I'D REALLY LOVE TO SEE AN
EXEMPTION IN THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT THAT ALLOWS FOR PROJECTS
LIKE OURS THAT ARE WORKING
TOWARDS IMPROVING FOOD SECURITY
BY USING SURPLUS. PUBLIC LAND
FOR GROWING- I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE A HUGE HELP I MEAN
ESPECIALLY AFTER SEVEN YEARS OF
WORKING ON THIS PROJECT TO BE
AMENDED THE GENERAL PLAN WE
NEGOTIATED A THIRTY YEAR LEASE
WE BY RESTORING THE SOIL WE
BUILT TEMPORARY INFRASTRUCTURE
WE CREATED A LONG TERM BUILDING
PLANET CAPITAL CAMPAIGN. AND
PASSED THE WHOLE SEQUEL PROCESS
WHICH WAS CRAZY DIFFICULT AND
NOW IS IN DANGER OF LOSING THE
WHOLE- THE WHOLE PROJECT. YOU
KNOW TOWARDS A GOOD ENDS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO SUPPORT LOW
INCOME HOUSING BUT I THINK THAT
THIS IS ALSO A NEED THAT OUR
COMMUNITY HOUSE. I ALSO WANT TO
SPEAK REALLY BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
AGRICULTURE INCENTIVE ZONES
THAT THAT FOLKS TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER THE URBAN AG- KIND OF
TAX INCENTIVE. SO THAT WAS
REALLY CELEBRATE IT WHEN IT
FIRST HAPPENS. EXCEPT WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE DETAILS REALIZE
THAT PLACES LIKE RICHMOND
DIDN'T QUALIFY BECAUSE WE HAVE
A POPULATION OF A HUNDRED AND
TEN THOUSAND INSTEAD OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND. SO
ALTHOUGH OUR- CITY GOVERNMENT
WANTED TO GET INVOLVED WE
ACTUALLY DID A QUALIFIED WOMAN
ONCE AGAIN I'M SORRY MY DOG.
ISRAEL DURING COVERED YOU'RE
GOOD. AND AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO BRING THAT UP AND SAY THAT
IF THAT IF THAT DIDN'T HAVE
THAT THE THAT SCALE OF CITY WAS
THE ONLY TYPE OF CITY WHO THAT
COULD BE INCLUDED IN THAT ACT.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT MORE CITIES
WOULD UTILIZE IT- BECAUSE THAT
IS REALLY A BARRIER RICHMAN IS
ACTUALLY REALLY RICH IN VACANT
LOTS AND WE HAVE LOTS OF FOOD
INSECURITY AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE
INVOLVED IN URBAN AGRICULTURE
SO WE COULD MAKE THE MAGIC CARE
BUT THERE'S LIMITATIONS TO WITH
THE WITH THAT ACT IS WRITTEN.
AND I JUST KIND OF PUT FORWARD
AGAIN THE SURPLUS LAND ACT JUST
AN EXEMPTION FOR FOOD SECURITY
PROJECT IS A GOOD USE OF
SURPLUS- PUBLIC LANDS AND THEN
JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OFFERED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE TRIED TO
ACCESS QUIPPED AND HEALTHY
SOILS- BUT BOTH ARE NOT SUITED
AT ALL FOR URBAN AGRICULTURE
EQUIPPED ESPECIALLY IS RELEASED
IS REALLY BACK TO SUPPORT
LARGER FARMS IT'S BASED ON
SCALE STEP YOU'RE GROWING AT A
VERY SMALL SCALE IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE THE AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT YOU GET. IS BASED ON
YOUR ACREAGE. SENATE THE M. OF
NEED WHAT YOUR TO DO- IT IS NOT
WORTH ALL OF THE PAPERWORK AND
ALL OF THE THINGS FOR A VERY
VERY SMALL SUPPORT THAT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY MEET YOUR NEEDS- IN
TERMS OF THE HEALTH DISORDERS
PROGRAM. AS I UNDERSTAND IT IT
ONLY REALLY SUPPORTS- FOLKS
THAT ARE STARTING NEW HEALTHY
SOIL PROJECT. PRACTICES SO WE
ALREADY ARE USING COVER
CROPPING AND- YOU KNOW DRIP
IRRIGATION AND KIND OF ALL THE
PRACTICE OF YOUR ORGANIC FARM-
FARMING OPERATION SO WE CAN'T
ACTUALLY ACCESS HEALTHY SOILS
EITHER. BECAUSE NOTHING WOULD
BE NEW WE'RE WE'RE ALREADY
DOING ALL THESE THINGS WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
THEM THE WAY THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO AN AT SCALE- AND FINALLY
WHEN I WANTED TO PUT FORTH AN
IDEA AND THAT IS. OUR VEGGIE
ARE EX PROGRAM IS REALLY
PHENOMENAL- TRYING TO ACTUALLY
WORK- TO PREVENT. ANY DISEASE
THAT MAKES OUR POPULATION
REALLY VULNERABLE TO THINGS
LIKE KOBE OR JUST. YOU KNOW A
LIFETIME ARE OLD AT THE END OF
LIFE BEING REALLY- JUST
DISASTROUS AND REALLY IMPACTFUL
FOR OUR HEALTH- SYSTEM WHICH IS
QUITE POOR WE LOST OUR LOCAL
HOSPITAL. A FEW YEARS BACK. AND
I'D REALLY LIKE TO PUT FORWARD
THE IDEA THAT. YOU KNOW FOOD
CAN BE AND SHOULD BE THOUGHT OF
AS PREVENTATIVE MEDICINE. AND
IF IT COULD BE INCLUDED IN
COUNTY AND STATE HEALTH PLANS
SO THAT A PRESCRIPTION FOR
HARDLY BOX OF FOOD FOR VERY LOW
INCOME FAMILY THAT WOULDN'T
NORMALLY BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT-
THAT ACTUALLY COULD BE
REVOLUTIONARY- BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT AS AN ACCEPTABLE THING TO
INCLUDE IN THE HEALTH AND
COVERAGE- BIKE MEDICINES. OR IN
SOME CASES SOME FOLKS YOU KNOW
CAN USE THEIR HEALTH PLAN TO GO
TO THE GYM OR WHATEVER- A BOX
OF. HEALTHY WHOLE NUTRIENT
DENSE FOOD EVERY WEEK COULD BE
A REALLY GOOD THING AND THAT
WOULD HELP US SUPPORT THE SMALL
FARMERS. YOU KNOW SUPPORT OUR
GROWING PRACTICE AND SUPPORT
FAMILIES THAT REALLY JUST CAN'T
AFFORD THIS KIND OF FOOD. AND
THEN TO PUT THAT OUT IDEA OUT
THERE AND. THEN FINALLY JUST
SAY- TO COME SEE US. I WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS PERFECT PEOPLE
USUALLY PRETTY NEW WE WELCOME
EVERYONE TO COME AND SEE THE
NORTH RICHMOND FARM AND ALL OF
OUR OTHER SITES- AND SEE WHAT
URBAN FARMS CAN DO TO IMPACT
HEALTH- TO CREATE LOCAL FOOD
BASED BUSINESSES- AND REALLY
INSPIRE YOUNG PEOPLE MAKE
POSITIVE CHANGES- NINETY THE
FARMERS THAT WE NEED IN THE
FUTURE. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME MISS ROBINSON
REALLY APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS AND I AGREE WITH YOU
KNOW- MOST IF NOT ALL OF WHAT
YOU SAID AS FAR AS YOUR TAKE ON
FOOD FOR MEDICINE- CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT OUR FOOD SYSTEM AND
REFORMINGIT WHERE WE CAN- IS
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY A GOAL OF
MINE AND- IS- YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT WE AS A STATE
NEED TO ASPIRE TO- ACCOMPLISH-
BUT WITH THAT BUT CERTAINLY
WILL TAKE UP YOUR OFFER TO GO
OUT THERE AND- AND- SEE THOSE
ARE C. OPERATION LOOK FOR TO
DOING THAT. AND OUR FINAL
PANELIST FOR THE DAY IS MINE
WHEN IS A CINEMA COUNTY FARMER
A CHAIR OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN
FARMERS ALLIANCE- IS THE WIND
GROWS HAIR LOOM GRAIN AND
SOUTHEAST ASIAN CROPS AS AN
ACTIVIST ORGANIZER FOR FARMING
EQUITY ISSUES INCLUDING
CURRENTLY AS CO DIRECTOR OF THE
NOW AND ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
LAND TENURE FOR FARMERS OF
COLOR AND WITH RESPECT FOR
INDIGENOUS SOVEREIGNTY- MISSING
WHEN- REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BEING WITH US THIS MORNING. I
EXTRAPOLATE. HELLO WELL IT'S
SORT OF GREAT ARTICLES THAT
IRISH GAELIC FOR IPC DAY THE
WIND DAY OF THE YEAR THAT I GET
TO FLEX MONEY CELTIC STUDIES
MAJOR SO AS NOT TO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY I'M REALLY HONORED
BOTH TO. HOW DO YOU RECEIVE ME
AND ALSO BUT MANY FARMERS UPON
HEARING THIS OPPORTUNITY
REACHED OUT NEED THE LEFT OF
VARIOUS IMPORTANT ISSUES. SUCH
THAT BY LAST NIGHT I CONSIDER
JUST GETTINGOUTLINED IN
REMARKS AND JUST SIMPLY READING
YEAR THEIR TEXTS AND- PLAYING
YOUR VOICE MAILS- BUYING BROWN
LIKE ONE IN THE MORNING. I
THOUGHT I HAD IT COVERED AND-
THEN I WOKE UP THIS MORNING TO
MESSAGES EXPRESSING ANXIETY AND.
DESPAIR AND CONDOLENCES- I
DIDN'T UNDER THAT. I READ THE
NUNES ABOUT THE ASIAN AMERICAN
WOMEN GUNNED DOWN LAST NIGHT IN
THAT MANNER. I THOUGHT ABOUT
MINIMUM. RACIALLY MOTIVATED
THREATS OF VIOLENCE THAT
EXPERIENCE LAWLER IS FARMING
MENDOCINO. FARMERSUSING
AMERICAN ALLIED FARMERS
ALLIANCE YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE
RESTAURANT GROCERY CUSTOMERS
LAST YEAR RODRIGUEZ IS
UNIVERSAL B. R. FUELED YOU KNOW
BY OUR PREVIOUS PRESIDENT
BECAUSE PEOPLE TO AVOID USING
AMERICAN ESTABLISHMENTS. KNOWN
EVEN ENTIRE CHINATOWNS. SO
THERE'S SO MUCH I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU- SO MUCH TO SYNTHESIZE
AMEX. YOU KNOW THE FEELING
BECAUSE YOUR- REPRESENTATIVES
OF LARGE DIVERSE CONSTITUENCIES
SO I DON'T I DON'T IN THE AIR-
BUT YOU KNOW I SIGNED UP FOR
THIS. I'M AN INDEPENDENT FARM
OWNER OPERATOR MANY AGENTS
ANIMAL ROTATION AND STRIKE
FARMING RELYING EXCLUSIVELY ON
OUR INCREASINGLY SCALE TO YOUR
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR NATION- AND I
MANAGING ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY MEMBER CSA- I NEEDED
THEIR SHARE INFORMATION LAST
NIGHT YOU KNOW SO. I'M ALSO A
MOTHER NONPROFIT DIRECTORS
MENTIONED AND I'M A MEMBER OF
THE COMMUNITY BEING HIT HARD BY
THE PANDEMIC IN MODERN SLAVERY
SYMPTOMS. OF SYSTEMIC ILLS. YOU
KNOW I'M HERE RIGHT YOU DURING
RIGHT AT THE TIME. IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING A WINTER BREAK I LOST
TEN PEOPLE. TWO MORE AND IT'S
NOT AGE. SO I AM LOOKING TO
COME WITH THIS ALL. I AM ALSO
WONDERING WHAT IS THE SO MUCH
WEIGHT ON MOMENT. WHY NOT SO
FARMERS FIELD THIS IS A CHIU.
TO CONNECT TO YOU. OKAY MAYBE
HEARD IN MEETINGS WE INCLUDING.
ON A REGULAR BASIS. SO THAT
WE'RE NOT RELYING JUST ON THESE
MOMENTS. THESE QUESTIONS CAN
HELP US ASSESS THE EFFICACY OF
IMPLEMENTING THE FORMER EQUITY
ACT AND- RACIAL EQUITY EFFORTS.
SO I AM I WAS A PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA FORMER JUSTICE
COLLABORATIVE AND THEN BEFORE
IT WAS THE COLLABORATION OF THE
COLLABORATIVE- THAT GROUP THAT
WAS A FOR MENTIONED AND- YEAH
CONCEDING. AND CHUCK
CHAMPIONING OF IRAQ ACT I STILL
TO THIS COMMITTEE FOUR YEARS
AGO- WITH THE HOPE THAT THE
ACT'S PASSAGE WOULD MEAN THAT
FARMERS OF COLOR WOULD HAVE A
GREATER. INFLUENCE AND NOT JUST
ACCESS INFLUENCE OVER THE
SECURITY PROGRAMS THROUGH
EQUITABLE PROCESS USE. FOR
EQUITABLE OUTCOMES. WELL I'M
KIND OF A FULL HEALTHY MIND. SO
WHEN ASKED AND STILL HOPE TO
MANDATE IN THOSE WORDS OF THAT
TAX THAT YOU KNOW CORDAGE THAT
ENSURES THE INCLUSION OF
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND RANCHERS IN THE DEVELOPMENT
ADOPTION AND IMPLEMENTATION AND
ENFORCEMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE LAWS. REGULATIONS
AND POLICIES AND PROGRAMS. I
THOUGHT IT INCLUDING WOULD MORE
POINTS OF CONTACT. HE'S MAKING
US THE GEYSERS AND MAYBE I'M
INTO STOCKS. TO ENSURE THE
SECOND COMES. NUMBER LIKE IT'S
NATURAL IT'S BEEN DONE FOR
YEARS AND THE FIRST ARMORED YOU
CAN UNIFIED PLATFORMERS-
HAPPENED YESTERDAY. SO
IMPLEMENTATION JUST HASN'T
SEEMS TO MATCH THE URGENCY OF
SOLVING THE PROBLEM THAT IS
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND THAT IS
OUR EXPOSURE TO PREMATURE DEATH.
PERSONALLY I'VE BEEN A FORMER
BUSINESS OWNER FOR SIX YEARS
KNOW HOW TO MOVE THREE TIMES
MOTION WAS RECENTLY BECAUSE MY
LANDLORD'S DAUGHTER BUILT A
HORSE RIDING FACILITY ON TOP OF
ME RAPING GREEN. BECAUSE HER OR
STRANGE FACILITY SHUT DOWN TO
PREVENT. AND IT WAS REALLY HARD
COMPLETE THE COURSE FOR THAT.
OKAY CHALLENGES ACCESSING
CAPITAL BUILD NEEDED REGIONAL
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH MORE
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE NOW AS
CRITICAL AS WE'VE CALLED. THE
FLOWER SHELVES LAST YEAR. YEAH
AND I FARMS THREE SEVEN
WILDFIRE SEASONS EVACUATING
TWICE I MOST RECENTLY WITH. A
SIX MONTH OLD BABY DESPERATELY
CRYING OUT OF HUNGER FOR ME- I
COULDN'T REACH HER BECAUSE I
WAS TRYING TO DRIVE US TO
SAFETY. SO BY THE TIME COMING
HERE. YOU KNOW OUR COMMUNITY
STILL KIND OF LARGELY REMAINED
ON OUR OWN- IN THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS OF SHELTER IN PLACE- I
SPOKE WITH HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
FARMERS LIKE. THE RIGHT PHONE
YOUR PEOPLE ASKING ME HOW TO
CHANGE THEIR SALES CHANNELS
REPEAT THEIR KIDS HAVE TAKEN
THE PRECAUTIONS- I KNOW IN THE
BALLPARK OR THOUGHT OF LAST
ABOUT ALL. I GATHERED FIRED BY
TALK. MUSICIANS AND MANDELA
PARTNERS ALL THE FIRST NATIONS
DON'T INSTITUTE COULD YOU ALL
OF OUR USERS. I PROJECT- AND
YOUR WE CREE EIGHT BY TALK WILL
FUND FORMER AND WE ARE STEWART
RECOGNIZE THAT ENDED PEOPLE.
DON'T NECESSARILY. UNDERSTAND
THE K. OF FARMERS AND RANCHERS
ARE AS YOU KNOW SEE IF MIGHT. I
DON'T REMEMBER REACHED OUT TO
START INTO. YES YOU TO SEE
WORLD AVAILABLE RIGHT THERE'S
THERE AREN'T ANY OTHER KINDS OF.
RESOURCES YEAR WE- AND RAISED
EIGHT THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR DIRECT LINE- AND SHIFT
THOUSAND DOLLAR FOR.
TRANSLATION AND CULTURE SKILLED
MAYES ON. THAT WOULD BE WORK TO
GET TO. I'M NOT EXPECTING THEM
TO FIND OUT- ALSO NEW FORM.
RIGHT NEEDED MARTIN MARKETS AND
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR
JOBS FOOD SO I RAISE TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR GROUP
PLANS FOURTEEN BY PROPERTIES.
IN SAN DIEGO. LONG FOR GOVERNOR
FUNDS THEIR AGGREGATE SYSTEM
AND FINALLY REST ON THIS TWO
HUNDRED. MODOC DOLLARS WERE
ABLE TO GET THEIR AGGREGATION
JUST STARTED AND GOT FOUR
HUNDRED ARE TO- FAMILY MANY AND
MANY OF RELY THEIR JOB. NO
LEARNING TO WRITE YOU KNOW
NATIVE COMMUNITY WILL JUST.
SUFFER WE SHOULD BE ADDRESS ON
THE COVER TO GO BASE BUT- I
USED MY LOGISTICS BACKGROUND
TWO MILLION SIX THOUSAND POUNDS
OF MEAT JANITOR RESERVATIONS-
IN DIRE NEED OF SEEING. MEET
YOU KNOW DAYS ON TOP OF THE
FOUR WEEKS THAT OTHERS HAD
ALREADY BEEN TRYING TO WORK ON
THIS- BECAUSE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE TAKES RESOURCES
OUT OF NATIVE. COMMUNITIES BUT
NOT IN. SO THAT WAS ONE TWENTY.
THREE YEARS. THE AMERICAN ACT
PASSED MOST THREE WE ARE JUST.
NO WONDER DO YOU KNOW WHY. BUT-
THIRTY MORE STRUCTURES TO BUILD
TRUST WITH FARMERS THEY HAD
SOMEONE TO CALL. NO ONE REALLY
STILL HUSTLING BURKE RESOURCES
INSTEAD OF HAVING AN EQUITABLY
RESPONSIVE GOVERNMENT. SO YOU
KNOW I THINK THERE'S THE
QUESTION OF WELL HOW HOW'S THE
FORMER ACTING USE. SO FAR THE-
BEST YEAR FAR DEFINITION HAS
BEEN USED TO CREATE SUB SIDES
FOR OUTREACH TO OUR COMMUNITIES
TO LEARN ABOUT PROGRAMS SUCH
AS- MEMBERS HEALTH IS WEALTH I
MEAN I REALLY PROGRAMS. THIS
PROGRAMS CREATED BY AND FOR
WHITE PEOPLE. CENTERING WHITE
PEOPLE AS THE NORM THE
UNIVERSAL AND PULLING RESOURCES
RUN ONE IS WHITE SUPREMACY. SO
ONE ONE THE TERM THAT WE CREATE
IS GETTING USE YOU KNOW WE
DIDN'T INTENDED FOR TO BE USED
TO ACCESS WHITE SUPREMACISTS
POLICIES INSTRUCTORS-
INTERPRETATION AND TRANSLATION
TO ACCESS WHITE SUPREMACISTS
POLICIES IS NOT EQUITY. EQUITY
OF ACCESS DOESN'T GUARANTEE THE
NEEDED. EQUITY OF OUTCOMES. AND
I'M NOT REALLY EVEN THAT WE
HAVE A UNDER OF. YOU THE CVS
CARE ACT REPORT DOESN'T THE-
AND THAT MAKES IT HARD TO THE
WORK WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
NEEDS. COM DEFINITION. SO THAT
THAT'S ACTIVELY USING MY
COMMUNITY THAT. AREN'T RECYCLED
IS THE PROPOSAL RESOURCING TO
COMPENSATE FOR THE
DISPROPORTIONATE EXTRACTION
OPPRESSION AND HARM. EQUITY
REQUIRES AN ACCURATE APPRAISAL
OF THE PAST WHOSE LAND AND
ALWAYS WORK IN MY ACCEPTANCE
STOLEN. YEAH THAT NEEDS TO BE
PAIRED WITH AN ACTION PLAN FOR
APOLOGY REPAIR AND HEALING. AND
THE REPORT DIDN'T DO THAT YEAH
I UNDERSTAND C. B. AS IN
PARKING UNDERSTANDING THAT'S
THE STREET RIGHT NOW. EDUCATING
PEOPLE ON THAT HISTORY IS NOT
EQUITY WORK ESPECIALLY MOST OF
THE PEOPLE ARE RIGHT IN THE
PARKING RESOURCE. TO BE PART
ABOUT SORT OF WORKPLACE. BUT
YEAH IT JACKSON KIND OF
OPPOSITE EQUITY. SO THIS IS WHY
EXPLICIT RAP WORK LIKE- WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES WE'RE
MENTIONED EXENCIAL- GOING BACK
TO THIS DEFINITION RACIAL
EQUITY BEING PROPORTIONATELY
FOR DISCORDANT EXTRACTION WE
NEED EQUITY OF PROCESS
OWNERSHIP AND OUTCOMES FOR
FARMERS OF COLOR. THIS NEEDS
INCLUDING US IN CLEAR
CONSISTENT ACCOUNTABLE DECISION
MAKING PROCESSES THAT ACCOUNT
FOR OUR CULTURAL WAYS
ORGANIZING AS WE'VE SEEN BRUCE
MICHAEL AND MANY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS DO YOU.
HAVE BEEN INCLUDES ABOUT LIKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS ACTION-
WE NEED OWNERSHIP OVER THE
CONDITIONS OF OUR LIVES
PROCESSES WERE OWNERSHIP. OF
THESE CONDITIONS GREENLANDERS
KNOWLEDGE MEANS OF PRODUCTION
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS.
ULTIMATELY WE NEED. THAT THIS
PROCESS IS AN OWNERSHIP FOR THE
AQABA. OUTCOMES YOU KNOW LIKE.
WE SEEN ALL THESE BY CHART
WHERE. A MORE RATES ARE CHARTS
AND SO THAT THE LONGEST BAR IS
WHITE PEOPLE AND THEN EVERYBODY
ELSE IS TO REMARKABLE. AND WE
NEED TO DO IS DO THE EQUITABLE
WORK SO THAT WE'RE ALL WE'RE
ALL AT THE MAX THEY'RE ALL.
THANKS FOR AND HEALTHY LIFE.
THE CARD ABOUT WORKS HERE IS
DOING THE WORK INSIDE I KNOW
THAT THE MANDATE- WITHINTHE
FORMER EQUITY ACT IS IT A
RELATIONSHIP BASED. TITANIC BUT
I THINK ALSO WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT EQUITY AMONGST OURSELVES-
IN THE REPORT TALKS ABOUT
HIRING EQUITY IN HIRING- AND
THEN WE TALK ABOUT. IN THE
NONPROFIT WORLD THEY MIGHT ALSO
HAVE TO BE EQUITY AND EATING
RIGHT BUT- BUT AS NEW PEOPLE
ARE HELD TO THE STANDARD. OF
HAVING ANY REFLECT FRAMEWORK
BUT PEOPLE ARE ALREADY IN THESE
POSITIONS HAVE A RACIAL EQUITY
FRAMEWORK EN MASSE CRITERIA FOR
THEM I'M TO YOU KNOW MAINTAIN
THEIR JOBS BECAUSE LEARN FROM
THE PEAK PER CASE THAT THE REST.
AS- WHICH IS LARGELY CONSIDER
TO TRY AND RECOGNIZE RECTIFYING
JUST YOU RACE I'M- THE REST
STAFF. WERE RACIST TOWARD US
FOR. STILL HELD THEIR JOB. NEWS
FORMER STILL TO BE THE SAME
PEOPLE AND REGIONAL ARE.
INTERNAL WORK IS. FOR GENET'S
THE FOUR YEARS IT'S SAY THAT
SPANISH PERIOD OF I'M BUT YOU
KNOW TWENTY TWENTY SHOWED MORE
PEOPLE THAT REALLY KNOW TRYING
TO. HOW. WORKINGS NEEDLESSLY
DIE IN ONE YEAR THIS CALL. IN
BLACK OF COLOR. THANK YOU MY
COMMUNITY SO DISILLUSIONED WITH
GOVERNMENT THAT GOING TO SLOW
THE GOVERNMENT CAN DO SWITCHED
WHEN IT WANTS TO HAVE BEEN A
GOOD URGENCY WAS SWIFT TO BAIL
OUT THE AIRLINES AND FIND
KHRISTICH HOUSE CHANGE. YEAH I
HEAR THAT PEOPLE SAY GOVERNMENT
AND CARE ABOUT US DOESN'T
LISTEN ANY ONE PARTICULAR GROUP
BUT WE SAW HOW SWIFTLY THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED. SODA TAX
LOBBYIST LARGELY SHE QUESTIONS
SHE CAN ACTIVELY STARTING
SERVICE EXPERTS LARGELY
ABDICATED. BY BLACKBURN EACH.
SO GOVERNMENT CAN MOVE QUICKER.
ARMS RACE EQUITY TO THE MERGER.
THAT AGE RANGE DEATH. WE CAN AT
YOU NEED COVERED BY FAR REALLY
PACKAGE FROM THIS. RECENT THE
CALIFORNIA JUST COLLABORATOR
STATE. FOR ABOUT THE RECORD.
EXIST THERE'S THE- YOU'RE
TWENTY RIGHT CALIFORNIA FARMER
REPORT- THAT HAS FOR. ALL SHE-
DIRECTOR AN ORGANIZATION
WORKING ON FORMALLY REFORM OF
COLOR WITH RESPECT FOR
INDIGENOUS. SOVEREIGNTY IN
REPATRIATION. SO WE CAN DO IT
WE HAVE THE SOLUTIONS. AND WE
WORK TOGETHER FOR EQUITY. SO
WHAT DOES NOT BE THE ONLY FORUM
YOU'RE HEARING FROM US. LET'S
TAKE THE PART EQUITY ACT TO THE
MAX AND ENGAGE IN A LITTLE COLD
PROCESS THESE FEDERAL RELIABLE
TRUSTED RELATIONSHIPS. CENTER
FARMERS OF COLOR FOR EQUITABLE
OWNERSHIP OF OUR STREETS AND
EQUITABLE OUTCOMES SO WE ALL
ENJOYED A HEALTHY AND PEACEFUL.
SOCIETY CORRECT. IS THE WHEN
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR IN THANK
YOU JOINING US MORNING I KNOW
WE- YOU KNOW A HAVE A HARD IN
ELEVEN. AND SO I. LOOK TO MY
COLLEAGUES- I IN. THE COMMITTEE
ROOM FOR QUESTIONS. FROM THIS
PANEL. THIS IS WHAT IT IS WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME WHAT
I'LL DO IS UP I'LL JUST MAKE A
STATEMENT BECAUSE WHAT.
PATRICIA DORIA. AND MY- MY
SISTERS IN THE STRUGGLE- YOU'VE
BEEN SAYING THINGS THAT I'VE
BEEN SAYING FOR A VERY VERY.
VERY LET'S SAY I'VE BEEN EIGHT
YEARS. VERY VERY LONG TIME- AND
TO HEAR IT. FROM A DIVERSE.
GROUP OF LATINO AFTER MERICAN
API. INDIVIDUALS ALSO SHOWS HOW
WE'RE ALL INTERCONNECTED. WE
ALL HAVE THE SAME STRUGGLE. WE
ALL NEED TO BAND TOGETHER- TO
MAKE SOMETHING HAPPEN AND IN
FACT- WHILE YOU WERE TALKING.
BY THE CHAIR LOOKEDAT ME AND
SAID MAYBE WE NEED A TASK FORCE
ON THIS MAYBE WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY. PULL THIS OUT DO IS
KIND OF A SUBSET OF IT AND-ACTUALLY DRILL DOWN. A AND JUST
TACKLE IT. ONCE AND FOR ALL. IN
A WE TALK ABOUT IT AND WE HAVE
A HEARING. WAIT WE GIVE IT TO
SOME FOLK AND THEN WE COME BACK
TWO OR THREE YEARS LATER WE
TALK ABOUT IT. WE GIVE IT TO
SOME FOLK. CAN WE CREATE SOME
PROGRAMS. AND THEN WE'RE BACK
AT IT AGAIN- LET'S. COME
TOGETHER- AND OBVIOUSLY WE
CAN'T DO IT ALL IN THE NEXT
ELEVEN MINUTES OR TEN MINUTES
BUT LET'S. COME TOGETHER AND
EVEN WORK WITH- WELL MY FRIENDS
ACROSS THAT AND OTHERS- TO
REALLY DELVE INTO THIS AND-
COME UP WITH SOME SOLUTIONS
THAT WE CAN THEN GO OUT
IMPLEMENTED. REVIEW IT SEE OUT
DO SOME ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
AS YOU MENTIONED. AND I
CONTINUE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN CURE THIS PROBLEM OF A- THE
CHALLENGES BERRIES
OPPORTUNITIES- AND FORMER
EQUITY DISPARITIES IN- LET'S
JUST FINALLY. PUT IT ON A
TOPPER INSTEAD OF. AS SOMETHING
WE NEED TO DO LATER THANK YOU
BASED ON THE NUMBER. QUESTION
MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
I REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
PANEL- A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
INFORMATION- BUT A GOOD POINTS-
MISS ROBINSON- A I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT- AND FRANKLY I
A CHALLENGE THE CHAIR TO WORK-
SOME SURPLUS LANDS- HEALTHY
SOILS INTO OUR ANNUAL AG
COMMITTEE BILL- IT AND I'LL
MAKE SURE- MY SIDE OF THE AISLE
HELPS- SUPPORT THAT- YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT ON THAT. IT AND I
GOTTA AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE-
MISTER JONES SAWYER IT'S- LET'S
DO A TASK FORCE LET'S GO IN
THERE AND LET'S TACKLE THAT. I
KNOW SITTING UP HERE ON THE
DIETS I JUST LOOK LIKE OKAY
WHITE BOY- FROM PUT ON FOR THE
BILL. BUT WAIT WHEN YOU GROW UP
POOR IN THE DIRT YOU GROW UP
POOR IN THE DIRT. AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT NEED HELP-
FROM FROM ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT EQUITY IS TO
ME IS MAKING SURE THAT THAT WE
GET INTO THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT. AS AS MY GRANDMA USED TO
PUT IT WE'RE ALL AMERICAN MUTTS
AND WE'VE ALL GOT TO WORK
TOGETHER- TO GET THINGS OUT
THERE TO ALL THE COMMUNITIES IN
AND EMBRACE. THAT BECAUSE IF WE
ARE ALL THE SAME A LIFE WOULD
BE BLAND. AND NOT FULL OF-
COLOR AND FLAVOR SO. WE GOT
ENSURE THAT INSURE THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER AND REALLY. YOU KNOW
IT IT'S NOT JUST. THE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BUT IT'S
THE THESE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WE'RE WE'RE ALL BRANCHED OUT.
IN REALLY INTO THE POVERTY SIDE
OF THIS- BECAUSE POVERTY DOES
NOT HAVE A COLOR. AND REALLY
LOOK DEEP IN MAKE SURE LIKE I
SAID EARLIER THAT THAT. THE
TECH SUPPORT THAT WE SAY WE
OFFER IS ACTUALLY GETTING DOWN
TO THE LEVEL WHERE EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY THAT WE HAVE AS
DIVERSIFIED AS WE ARE. CAN
ACTUALLY USE IT AND UNDERSTAND
IT IN IN PHILLY IN TOUCH IT IN
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
BECAUSE IT'S IT IS GREAT WHEN
THE STABLE YEAH WE GOT
TECHNICALS ABOARD. A HERO OVER
THIS NONSENSE FOR SEVEN YEARS.
AGO WE GOT A PROGRAM FOR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. BUT IF
NOBODY KNOWS HOW TO ACCESS THAT
GET A HOLD OF IT IT'S
WORTHLESS. SO LET'S LET'S DO
THAT TASK FORCE READ READ YOU
ALL THE- ALL ALL COULD SHARE
WITH YOU. BECAUSE I'M ONLY
REPUBLICAN SO. YOU KNOW I DON'T
GET THE CHAIR THANKS. BUT I'M
I'M DOWN LET'S GET IT DONE.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR- AND WITH
THAT I REALLY WANT TO THANK.
OUR SECOND PANEL YOU KNOW
REALLY APPRECIATE. YOU GUYS
MAKE THE TIME FOR US AND LOOK
FORWARD TO. THE FUTURE
ENGAGEMENT AND- HAVING AN IN
PERSON VISIT HERE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE BUT REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND ALL THE
INFORMATION I THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND SO AND SO WITH THAT WE ARE
GOING TO TURN THE LAST SIX
MINUTES THAT WE HAVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT- I WOULD REMIND THAT.
ALL COMMENTS BE LIMITED TO TWO
MINUTES PER CALLER. AND PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND IF
APPLICABLE THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT- AND- ALSO PLEASE
KEEP THE TOPIC OF THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- YOU KNOW
IN. YOUR COMMENTS AND SO. DO WE
HAVE MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE
HERE WHO'D LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. WE DO SIR IT'S YOURS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS- YEAH.
HANDJOB MONIES ROOSEVELT TIME
TO SING. AND I STANDING HERE
REPRESENTING MYSELF AN AURA OF
ENTITIES I'M REPRESENTING OUR-
CALIFORNIA FOR MAJESTIC
COLLABORATIVE I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ECONOMIC SECURITY VOTOMATIC
PARTIAL COMMITTEE ARMORED
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OPKO FATHER
I'M ALSO REPRESENTING MY FONG
TORRES FONG AIN'T- STAY HERE
ALSO REPRESENTING OUR THE KAKA
TRY AND APPROACH- BY SO HAN I'M
SO HAPPY TO BE HERE HI- WAS
INVOLVED WITH THE SB THIRTY
FOUR EIGHT HUNDRED KC ARE WE
MAKING FOR STRONG AS A TOOL TO
GET PAST. ALSO I'M SO HAPPY YES
COMPANIES TO USE FOUNDATION
THAT ALLOW US TO HIDE THIS
COMPETITION- ATTY IS ALSO
BROUGHT. UP AN OPPORTUNITY ARE
LIKE IBM RATE TODAY I'M SO
HAPPY TO THAT- I BRIEFLY I
WANNA I WANNA GIVE- MY
BACKGROUND- ONE EFFECTIVELY TO
OF A FARM AND AGRICULTURE- SO
I'M A FARMER WE'LL GET IT FROM-
HI ACCORDING TO MY KNOWLEDGE
HI- THE FIRST FORMAL HE- THEY
IN CALIFORNIA THAT.
PARTICIPATED OUR TEAM THE
NATIONAL ORGANIC PROGRAM. IT IS
SEEM TO BE I WANTED TO. FIRST
IN THE NATION ALL MAYBE THE-
FIRST PHAM I'M SAY THAT TO SAY
THAT I THURMOND NARRATIVE. FROM
WE DO A LOT- ALSO I PARTICIPATE
IN INDIA THE PROGRAM A- HAVE
OUR METAL QUALITY HE SAID THE
PROGRAM FIVE DOT HAVE. SO
YOU'VE ALWAYS I'M ALWAYS A LINE
WITH THE WITH THEWITH THE
PROCESS AND THE AND- WHAT USDA
HAS TO A PERCENT. HI AND
INTERNET IS NOT HE IS AND SIR
SO THAT- IS TWO MINUTES IF YOU
CAN WRAP UP OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
RIGHT AGAIN- THERE'S A LOT TALK
HERE THIS MORNING TAT. REALLY
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE OUR I. P.
EVOLVED. OR THE- HOPE PROGRAM
ADA SOMEBODY'S. I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE A CONNECTION. TO SUBMIT-
OF WHAT I'M WORKING ON NOW.
PETER OUT FOR OF ME DATA THE
RACE. OUR A- RAKING OF- IT'LL
PLAN. DIALECT PERCENT TO THIS
BY WELL THANK REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS- AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY. THANK
YOU SIR AND SO WITH THAT NOT
SEEN ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE
HEARING FOR COMMENTS OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR- OUR FIRST CALLER. IF
WE HAVE ANY COLLEGE IN THE CAT.
THANK YOU VERY I'LL LET DOWN
THE LINES IF YOU DO WISH TO
MAKE A PROBABLY COMMENT TODAY
SINCE PRESSED FOLLOWED ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. IN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE SO YOU
CAN ASK YOUR QUESTION IN PLACE
YOU BACKING Q. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR QUESTIONS ONE ZERO. AND OUR
FIRST. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL COME
FROM WIND FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FOURTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN YES. GREAT COME MORNING
JERRY NESS AND MEMBERS- THIS IS
JANE YOU CAN USE WHAT THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS- I WANT TO EXPRESS THAT
WE GET CAST REALLY GRIEVED THE
LOSS OF LIFE IN ATLANTA LAST
NIGHT AND STAND FIRMLY AGAINST
THE HATE THAT CONTINUES TO BE
DIRECTED AT ASIAN AMERICANS-
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT. TO SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS KASPIYSK DEEPLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGE SUPPORT
FOR GREATER LANGUAGE
APPROPRIATE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS IMPROVING
ACCESS TO RESOURCES LOANS AND
LAND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
NOW TO ADDRESS SOME OF. THESE
FIRST PRIORITIES AS THE
LEGISLATURE FINALIZES THE NEXT
ROUND OF EARLY ACTION BUDGET
ITEMS- AND PLEASE BE SURE IT
INCLUDES GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED-
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FUNDING FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL
FARMERS THAT- MR IN HOUSE
DESCRIBED THIS IS CRITICAL IF
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THESE FARMERS ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS. THE SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
AID THAT'S BEING APPROVED
THROUGH THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN AND PRIOR CO THE PRACTICES
THAT IS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW- I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TO PLEASE ACT
QUICKLY ON THAT. WE ACCOUNT FOR
EXCITED BY YOUR COMMITMENT
COMMITTEES FOCUS HERE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HELPING EXPAND
WITH THE NUMBER OF VOICES AND
INFORM OUR COLLECTIVE WORK IN
PARTICULAR WE HAVE WE KNOW WE
HAVE MUCH TO DO TO LEARN FROM A
WIDE VARIETY OF MULTICULTURAL
PERSPECTIVES PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO REPRESENT INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO ARE
ENCOURAGED AND INSPIRED BY
SECRETARY LOS FELIZ AND HE HAS
WORKED AT CDFA AND INDEED AND
CAN THE IMPORTANT WORK
OCCURRING AT ALL LEVELS AND THE
DEPARTMENT ENGAGED IN RACIAL
EQUITY TRAINING AND LEARNING
THEIR EAGER TO LEARN FROM THE
WORK OF THE FARMER FARMER COLOR
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. CATHERINE
ARE FORMER MEMBER FIRST LOOK
FORWARD TO CAN. TO CALL WITH
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I MEMBERS
OF THE- COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
MUCH. AND THAT WAS RIGHT AT TWO
MINUTES IN THANK YOU JAMIE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS- OPERATOR IF YOU CAN-
UP LINE FOR OUR NEXT CALLER IF
THERE'S SOMEONE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO PUT
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FINAL EVAN YOU ARE IN. HI THERE
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES HI MY
NAME'S LED CUNNINGHAM- THE
MEXICAN AMERICAN YOUNG FARMER
IN L. A. COUNTY YOUTH EDUCATOR
FOR TEN YEARS AND CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR WITH THE
NATIONAL YOUNG FARMERS
COALITION- FIRST OFF ON THE
BREEDING AND- WHAT THAT BUT
HERE'S THE COSTLY STATE NAMED-
IN TODAY SESSION AND THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THIS- I'M AWFULLY
GLAD WE SPEAKING ABOUT URBAN AG
AND IT'S NOT A COINCIDENCE-
THAT AIRBAG HAS NOT BEEN
INCLUDED RIGHT NOR THAT THAT
PERCENTAGE ESPECIALLY
DISADVANTAGED MEMBERS THIS IS
SO LOW COMPARED- EVEN THOUGHT
THE WHOLE WE ARE THE MAJORITY
RIGHT AND PUT THAT THE IMPACT
OF STRUCTURAL RACISM IN THE
STATE MUST BE REALLY
INTENTIONAL- AND WHO WHERE HOW
IT WILL REPORT THAT. FALSELY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS WHILE
ABOLISHING COULD APARTHEID AND
STRUCTURAL RACISM- WE NEED
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE IN DEEP
COLLABORATION WITH INDIGENOUS
SOVEREIGN NATION FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED OR NOT AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA FARMER JUST
COLLABORATIVE MANY AMAZING
FARMERS AND ORGANIZATIONS TODAY
OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT THEY NEED TO
SUPPORT THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THE FARMER EQUITY ACT HAD THE
POTENTIAL TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN
THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THESE GROUPS
NAMED- I I'M THANKFUL FOR YOUR
TIME AND ALSO- AS A YOUNG
FARMER- COLLISION WE HAVE OVER
EIGHTY FIVE FORMER MEMBERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA- YOUNGER HUPP
YOUNG FARMER HUB IN CENTRAL
COAST AND SOUTHERN. CALIFORNIA
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH JOHN THANK YOU SO MUCH. AT
THE YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS PRE
IT OPERATOR THE ANY COLOR IN
THE QUEUE. NOT AT THIS TIME
MISTER. OKAY SO WITH THAT
REALLY APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
ONE IT'S KILLING UP IF YOU
WOULD LIKE AB SKIN UP THEY JUST
TOOK HIMSELF OUT I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT THANK YOU OPERATOR
AND SO WITH THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE MEMBERS BE PART OF-
THIS HEARING WANT TO THANK OUR
PANELISTS WHO JOINED US AND
IT'S BEEN VERY. INFORMATIVE AND
AN INMATE AND HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS OF THE
FORMER EQUITY ACT TO OUR
FARMING- TO- TO OUR FARMERS
RANCHERS IN HERE IN THE STATE
THE STATE CALIFORNIA AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ENSURING THAT- WE
CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION AND
AGAIN HAPPY ST PATRICK'S DAY.
AND HAVE A GREAT DAY. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THAT DOES
CONCLUDE OUR CONFERENCE.